tous les plus grands tournois d'échec il
se déroulent en présentiel ou en ligne
vivez comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
bases retrouvez toutes les infos
essentiels comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et salut yosh j'espère
que tu vas très très bien ouais salut
stuff ça va très très bien effectivement
très contente d'être là
la première avec moi c'est vrai qu'on
avait fait une seule battle non pardon
moi
ça y est c'est un très bon début de
semaine
première
bêtise oui non on avait fait un match ça
c'était mal terminé pour moi
et mais c'est la première fois qu'on est
vraiment en stream tous les deux donc
vous avez très peur de te voir en tout
cas et
donc ce tournoi vous savez aujourd'hui
c'est la honte 4 du Nord-Ouest on a de
très très belles affiches qu'on a ici
gokash avec les Blancs contre manus
Carlson en 69
et d'ailleurs ok
j'avais oublié mais gookesh a battu
Magnus pendant le Blitz d'une norweet
qui sert à déterminer si quel joueur
parmi les 10 vont avoir 5 fois les
blancs et 4 fois les noirs et d'ailleurs
Magnus pour la première fois à finir le
deuxième partie de tableau et va avoir
donc cinq fois les noirs et 4 fois les
blancs ce qui est évidemment un gros
désavantage à ce niveau là et entre
autres il doit sa mauvaise performance à
la défaite contre gokash qui a eu lieu
le jour de 17 ans de GO cash quoi donc
parfois on est très très sérieux quand
on a 17 ans elle a c'est clair
maintenant tu le connais en plus non si
vous avez joué à Cannes ensemble on a
joué
supportez pas à Cannes on a joué en Top
12 à l'époque ensemble avec avec Google
alors je peux te dire que des 11-0 je
lui en ai mis à tout va non je parle
comme bien sûr il était nul comme un
manche mais l'adresse par contre c'était
pas la même mais mais oui c'est on l'a
vu en Top 12 il était avec
Murali aussi et de la bataille et c'est
vrai que j'en garde un énorme un très
très bon souvenir franchement il avait
13 ans
25-50 et c'était
juste trop gentil le matin il est nous
aider pour les préparations il n'aura
pas c'était juste c'était une vraiment
une super expérience de l'avoir dans
l'équipe c'est marrant tu vois tu es au
petit déjeuner tu viens de te lever
donc bon tu as la tête
là où tu veux et
en fait lui il est avec Prague il avait
sur leur téléphone une étude qui
ressemble à rien et il faisait ça
pendant deux heures pendant qu'il bouge
pas et donc moi des fois je regarde la
position
trop compliqué quoi vraiment ça fait
trop compliqué c'est marrant parce que
c'est une expression réseau des études
au petit déjeuner quand même en fait
mais en fait de la prépa parce que il se
préparait dans les ouvertures mais
c'était pas
là où il bossait le plus apparemment le
matin enfin je sais pas combien
d'arriver mais vraiment trois quatre
heures de de calcul le matin et tu dis
pour natation n'arrive pas à plus
de 2717 ans par hasard
bon alors vu que les parties ont
commencé on peut peut-être s'en parler
parce que c'est déjà un tantinet
bizarrement
très précoce on va se voir un très très
sûrement un G5 arrivé peut-être de
Magnus
ouais alors pas forcément tout de suite
et puis on peut attendre peut-être que
les Blancs par exemple après il faut
trouver un coup haute que j'ai 5 ans
alors bon dans les aliens il y a le coup
acide qui a un coût hyper hyper naturel
qui permet en fait qui menace aussi
d'enfermer le fou et de le manger
surtout contre le cavalier et on a aussi
maintenant qui vachement la mode le coup
à 5 qui empêche B4 elle prend un peu de
l'espace ce côté là donc
à part un six ou à 5 qu'est-ce que tu
vois comme petit rock
un perroquet bon moi je suis toujours
partisan de
soit jouer G5 soit jouer rock mais au
top niveau et puis l'ordinateur il
conseille souvent de faire les deux
quand même donc ça c'est pas un souci
juste moi je suis je suis un peu plus
précautionneuse on va dire quand je fais
j'ai 5 j'ai pas envie de roquet en plus
mais surtout si l'adversaire n'a pas
encore ok mais ok il peut tout à fait
proposer un
roc puis j'ai 5 en plus ça va être le
pion déjà en C3 le sacrifices marche
beaucoup moins bien que tu allais
prendre le 5 parce que le cavalier peut
pas venir en C3 pour participer à
l'attaque ensuite donc
je crois que c'est tout à fait possible
à 6 à 5 je suis peut-être moins certaine
que les Blancs après faut que j'ai 5
fois H4 et envie de jouer B4 à 4 et
l'expansion à l'eldom parce que le Fou
est en coincé a le droit maintenant je
pense je pense que ça a plus se jouer
sur la pouss par exemple ou même
l'attaque classique
à la loi alors un truc peut-être c'est
aussi ce qu'il faut toujours faire un
pas ton succion mais bon ça c'est plus
moi à mon niveau
encadrant précoce c'est le plan h3g4
pour un problème blanc aussi un mois qui
déteste me faire attaquer mais bon ça je
vois je vois mal goût cache tenter ça
contre un thème quand même mais
clairement c'est jamais idiot on sait
jamais
donc la rupture même tourgé on en est
pas là mais les coûts sont assez typique
donc après comme tu disais c'est vrai
que petit rock ne veut pas dire qu'on
fera pas G5 et des fois bon c'est vrai
que moi quand je balance J5 je perds pas
le droit derrière
parce que bah du coup H4 peut venir plus
facilement mais
après c'est en fait l'ordinateur de fin
tellement bien qui l'a montré que que je
sens que j'ai quasiment toujours bon
alors déjà on peut expliquer vraiment
pourquoi je sens que c'est bon c'est
parce que le fou en G3 après il faut le
mettre
j'ai pas fait jouer un rock par exemple
ouais
j'ai 5 donc là le blanc peuvent être un
sacrifice avoir une pièce de moins en
consommant d'options mais il y a pas
assez d'attaques normalement mais c'est
jamais totalement idiot non plus en
pratique
ce genre de truc ça peut ça peut arriver
mais normalement il y a pas assez de jeu
et du coup faut j'ai trois efforcé et ce
fou fait vraiment pitié en G3 quoi il
peut être mauvais tant que les pions
noirs E5 en G5 reste ce fruit sera
mauvais pour tout le droit de la partie
il y a un plan potentiel de bouger le
cavalier F3 puis du F3 puis de jouer FF2
mais bon ça prend beaucoup de temps et
on peut en être très loin et le pire du
pire pour finir sur ce mauvais faute à
trois c'est si jamais en cas de Fougères
après de loin vas-y j'ai cinq fois j'ai
trois
les cinq projets 3 le pire scénario bah
oui il y a une partie très connue tu vas
me la
Winter Capablanca si on imagine là un
coup totalement idiot mais juste pour
montrer la structure dame 1 pour se
créer pour un F3 et donc là c'est qu'un
Noir positionnel donc allez voir pour
celles et ceux qui connaissent pas
encore winter Capablanca il y a aussi
dans le même style un short cramique une
partie au cramé qu'évidemment on fait la
leçon à short
ou ce fou un j'ai trois en fait ne
jouera plus jamais on est parti
d'ici donc j'arrive à jouer F4 puis est
propre pour sortir donc bonne chance
[Musique]
elle est fantastique hein c'est un grand
grand classique et en tant qu'entraîneur
s'il vous plaît
ça m'a rapporté des dizaines de cours
mais non mais c'est clair c'est c'est un
très très grand classique et ça vous
montre des fois que les fous on les met
sur les grandes diagonales et pas
forcément bah tu vois sur les petites
quoi donc
évidemment me fait mentir tout de suite
je joue à 5 et non pas si comme j'aurais
fait donc sur moi qui a considéré que
même si le Fou est en H4 B4 l'expansion
à la dame devait être une idée
parce que donc à 5 il faut aussi
comprendre que c'est assez moderne comme
conception il y a encore 20 ans et 20
ans à l'échelle du jeu de chaque c'est
très récent les grands maîtres il y a 20
ans je mettrais très très bien mais
personne ne joue à 5 et jouer à 5 tu te
serais fait critiquer par n'importe quel
joueur mais tu comprends rien aux échecs
à 5 déjà tu menaces pas qu'elle va dire
5 évidemment
et la case B5 pas très très désagréable
après un fou B5 par exemple voilà c'est
un coup que des Blancs ont alors
qu'après à 6 il y a pas assez
désavantages donc n'importe quel grand
maître il y a 20 ans on aurait critiqué
le coup à 5 lever les yeux au ciel mais
tu comprends rien bon et maintenant
c'est plus souvent joué on va plus
souvent à 5 racisme même si à 6 ça reste
toujours très courant dans l'italienne
évidemment après il y avait une une idée
qui avait popularisé un petit peu je
crois que c'est viglyrène avec l'idée de
mettre la dame en
7 ça c'est génial bon le concept il est
génial tu as l'impression qu'il fait
petit rock avec les Noirs
c'est juste comme la dame en A7
c'est peut-être moins vrai parce que
c'est souvent pour mettre une pression
sur abdos aussi
le blanc s'il y aura quelque chose
d'horreur depuis un V2
peut-être un peu fébrile en cas de la
massette bon après ça contrôle la case
de 4 aussi etc donc cette manœuvre qu'on
adore
pour le coup j'ai plus l'arrêt de la
jouer ils étaient bon c'est très connu
hein c'était une est indienne avec un
dame D8 dame B8 damasset
c'est
Rubinstein
j'utilise souvent aussi
[Musique]
pour aller en B6 ensuite et en B4 après
etc
elle est très cool aussi c'est une
partie que j'ai déjà montré mais pareil
que toi ma mémoire me fait un peu des
fois je crois qu'on a les mêmes dossiers
il y a de l'entraîneur qui monte
quasiment que les parties récentes moi
je suis vraiment team classique quoi
quand même et donc voilà donc à 5 est-ce
qu'on se bat un petit tour de stade pour
voir un peu ce qui se passe et
intéressant de regarder alors attends
parce qu'il faut que je regarde un petit
peu tout et alors donc contre karassen
c'est ça un guirin à kamura table 2 je
vous mets les caméras des joueurs en
même temps
donc ça c'est une
ressortisses c'est pas le Cool plus
jouer maintenant mais bon ça a toujours
été joué en deux capsule
d'attention et d'ailleurs guérit la peau
beaucoup beaucoup joué avec les Noirs
c'était un tournoi de Bullet
au Pays-Bas et c'était assez marrant
comme moi j'ai trop trop kiffé et j'ai
fait deux fois et
d'ailleurs elle est partie elle est sur
YouTube
[Musique]
sur Youtube je crois que c'est une ligne
où il m'a fait dépendre mais j'ai deux
fois et deux fois la
recevrilaté
la partie où j'ai fait des branches
j'avais une belle partie bon après c'est
des Bullet c'est bon à la fin j'avais
une descendre mais j'ai même pas et la
deuxième alors c'est celle là et j'ai
réussi alors je sais plus comment mais
j'ai réussi à lui manger la tour à chute
avec la dame
va savoir comment gérer madame en H4
et j'avais fait de manger la tour je
sais plus comment mais je le mange à la
tour et son roi et c'est parti là-bas et
quand son roi il est arrivé en C7 images
de fou baisser de partager
voilà j'ai perdu comme ça et c'était
atroce et bref on s'en fout de ma vie
mais
c'était cette partie là contre guéri qui
est blanc petit rock c'est normal et
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est la coupe
malin un petit RACA parce qu'en fait il
y a plein de gens qui jouent ici des
codes Détroit c'est sur le système qui
sont assez thématique dans dans tout ce
qui est donc vous trois ça dépend dans
tout ce qui est en solimo mais en fait
il y a des lignes où tu joues toujours
avec des cartes très vite et par exemple
sur Full Z3 et ben Yamina cavaliers
5 avec C4 suivi de D4
et c'est pour ça que
on joue pas des trois pour le jour en un
coup en fait c'est plus surprenant
des trois probable mais pas certain
donc dans
cette on connait l'enjeu l'enjeu de la
Rosso limos c'est vraiment de contrôler
la case de 5 et donc la baignoire
contrôle le 5 empêche un peu enfin ou
pas E5 alors ce coup de 5 c'est un coup
qui peut être à la fois hyper fort comme
peut être assez mauvais parce que ça
empêche cavalier FC c'est ça empêche un
petit peu le noir de se développer par
exemple même là comme des 6 donc envie
de manger tu dis bah écoute puis on
prend c'est interdit
et d'un point tu as une structure qui
est très mauvaise
et donc en fait le problème c'est le
fiancé c'est
souvent on va jouer souvent des idées
comme ça pour essayer de vraiment les
pions sur blanc et empêcher ses cadres
et après il y a plusieurs plusieurs
motifs plusieurs manières d'attaquer ce
petit pion en 5 mais
l'idée de jouer 5 c'est intéressant
parce que ça empêche ces trucs là mais
des fois ça peut être pas bon parce
qu'il y a des il y a des réponses avec
leur F6 ce qui va tuer le Pione 5 et
plus tard s'emparer de du centre
académie
il faut rappeler que les Blancs
donnaient la paire de fou au troisième
coup
quatrième mais du coup à l'ouverture de
la position pas très dangereuse
je vais préparer un truc comme ça avec
le noir avec les deux fous et le centre
ça peut faire très mal donc des fois le
5 à l'air intéressant des fois pas
forcément ça dépend des positions donc
là il a joué des trois ok quand je
connais pas du tout
E5 voilà on le voit aussi après des
princesses
oui ça peut servir également d'un
évidemment mais aussi de pas de pas
dévoiler la place du cavalier encore
donc il faut jouer un coup utile dame
c'est ça se marie très bien avec tout ce
système là pas de content d'avoir un
cavalier encore un G8 très souple et pas
forcément le mettre en M6 juste après
quoi
[Musique]
que je crois pas trop
ça dépend des idées comme ça des fois
avec des processus notamment je crois
qu'ici c'est un grand coup
et genre sur C3
mais plein de parties comme ça avec des
six et 6 cavaliers
mais mais jamais vraiment
donc c'est l'idée
on peut se permettre un peu plus que
d'habitude quand les blancs on peut le
faire blanche évidemment
ok alors on en est où là exactement
alors je vais regarder ces trois cabinet
6 D4 prise et prise donc là
on peut se poser la question entre
plusieurs
de récupérer les pions tout de suite E5
c'est vraiment très tentant
peut-être pour faire dame prendre des
cartes ensuite mais
il peut y avoir une petite attaque sur
case noire quand même je serai déjà très
fier avec les Noirs
juste d'un match 4 non
ça fait un peu attaque de belote mais
[Rires]
il faut quand même se développer un peu
avant mais mais bien sûr en fait tu vas
jouer un cavalier de 4 tu vas taper F6
parce que généralement aussi c'est
dangereux de jouer G6 et aussi en même
temps dans une partie ça vaut beaucoup
les gaz noire et là écoute moi j'aime
beaucoup les j'aime beaucoup
c'est un coup de développement préalable
mais
clairement c'est ça fait un peu peur
toutes ces cases noires affaiblies
si je prends des quatre et que je prends
ici
n'a pas de bonnes réponses je crois
c'est obligé de jouer
cavalier ça
ouais non c'est horrible c'est la partie
il y a eu un problème maintenant
[Musique]
il peut aussi
parce que la dame au centre elle est
toujours bien placée quand elle peut pas
se faire attaquer par un courtier il est
là évidemment sur la même diagonale que
le fou G7 c'est un peu terrifiant mais
bon en même en cas de Calais de ça qu'on
bouge la dame pour l'instant il y a pas
il y a pas d'autres sur un coup
de développement
à 6 ça peut commencer à barder un peu
sur case blanche
très naturel après à ce qu'il y a
d'autres coups
je réparer Disney
[Musique]
en plus même ça ça fixe le pion de cette
pour l'instant donc
là moi je me demandais cavalier des cinq
du coup maintenant
qu'il va nous faire une immortelle mais
je crois pas après on peut encore jouer
mais bon là ça je pense que c'est un peu
moins de sens dans le sens qu'à dire ok
tout à l'heure ou maintenant il y a des
six et l'ouverture de la pollution après
prise prise dans cette croix surprise
dans cette 3 dossiers c'est ça ouais je
sais pas quel ordre
4 et tout mais
[Musique]
c'est marrant si je prends là tu prends
là je prends là tu prends là
mais en fait je pense que peut-être pas
pousser tout à l'heure tu vois il pousse
pas les deux ils veulent pas
je ne sais pas ce qu'on ne comprend pas
mais
c'est peut-être juste totalement la
théorie ah oui oui est-ce que je connais
pas
très fourni mais s'il y a encore des
parties de la basse
[Musique]
donc
isolé ça vaut la tour ça renforce le
contrôle central de noir
donc ça semble une bonne nouvelle quand
même ça donne
l'ordinateur
[Musique]
on n'a pas proposé le coup théorique on
a proposé le coup de l'ordre on a
proposé la nouveauté bon c'est pas mal
j'ai pas compris
[Musique]
oui non ça va c'était trop logique pour
que ça soit pas au moins correct ok
je pense que cinq va être
vraies noires c'est là où on a une pièce
mineure de plus c'était les trois pièces
mineures des blancs peuvent contrôler
les case noir potentiellement alors que
les Noirs eux auront toujours un faux se
casse blanche qui sera inoffensive dans
le jeu surface
donc
voilà avec les Blancs jouent sur la case
noire donc avec des coups comme
cavaliers 4 faut que J5 ça peut arriver
au G5 une petite menace mais donc
j'imagine qu'il y avait le 8 c'est pour
se diriger vers la case E6
tranquillement on vient c'est ça
en tout cas sur foger 5 on joue C7 et
puis après on regarde où est-ce qu'on va
mais
alors en fait l'entreprise que moi
j'aurais préféré
[Musique]
tu commences à calculer comme ça on va
pas s'entendre
8 c'est une belle tactique franchement
une qualité enfin j'ai deux pièces
et voilà donc cavalier prend qui va
aller prendre c'est pour naturel mais
surtout recette je pense juste
et j'arrive à me défendre je pense
correctement et
5 et 5 après des cinq cavaliers
[Musique]
on pas affaiblir encore plus la case
noire là cette tomate puni tout de suite
est-ce que tu vois
[Musique]
en fait
bon
ce qui se passe
fous des quatre encore attention tu
reprends F3 pour calculer là ce qui se
passe après tout ça donc tu m'as appris
là j'ai pas une tactique avec fupron
avec cavalier
elle descend mais bon je mange une
pierre
mais bon ouais ça n'a pas mal quand même
donc en fait on voit pas mal de jeux je
suis persuadé que ce pion il va être
sacrifié en fait parce qu'on n'est pas
c'est mieux d'être actif et il va me
donner un pion de ouvrir les fous j'ai
la paire de fou il faut que je joue la
pollution plutôt qu'à jouer un peu comme
tout raciste ou V5
donc dynamique
je peux
ne pas manger qui est un peu le rêve si
tu veux des des Noirs salut Yumé
et je lui ai fait je lui ai fait la
petite devinette et j'ai dit non non non
non non non
et là il te voit donc du coup
bon bah ça sera très intéressant de voir
si effectivement n'a qu'à décide de
sacrifier le pion alors après les deux
joueurs en l'air de connaître donc
évidemment c'est un petit avantage quand
même sur nous qui découvrons la position
mais j'aime beaucoup l'idée de ne pas
défendre le premier site de façon tourbé
vite c'est tellement horrible
un aveu de chaque
manger on va vite OK
après
si je mange là il y a tout qui s'ouvre
et il va y avoir des il va se passer des
choses là je pense donc
il y a beaucoup emprise et je sais pas
[Musique]
non mais c'est très marrant beaucoup
les quatre
[Musique]
et en fait bon après tout pourquoi pas
si jamais le faire ça ça va mais c'est
vrai que cette ligne avec on laisse le
pion enfin la tension peut-être qu'elle
était pas si simple et ouais
ok bon et ben avoir comment ça se
développe tout ça mon expérience
donc je crois qu'on a le droit de voir
ce site je suis pas totalement certaine
[Musique]
on va aller voir
alors
ça la structure d'une petite d'un petit
Marshall mais on va on va voir ce qui
s'est passé je fais là je fais la ça
la même partie entre
Naka et
les blancs n'avaient pas de pions plus
mais
les noirs
mais les Blancs avaient toujours la
paire de Fougères
n'a pas été joué dans les deux derniers
championnats du monde où les Noirs
menacé de le faire et les blancs à
chaque fois refusé de rentrer dedans
parce que au top niveau ben on voit
souvent ce genre de finale où les Blancs
ne font aucun avantage
[Musique]
alors après peut-être que juste il en
peut plus et il veut faire le il va y
avoir quand même une journée de repos
mais
en fait ok le Thomas est difficile pour
orienter qui a joué
après il a joué alors là
le penalty des autres quoi c'est
vraiment
quand ils ont les Noirs
tu peux pas te permettre de pas battre
le pauvre Ariane
mais ça date assez dur psychologiquement
puis en plus c'est ton affaire mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec les open que nous
on fait quand tu joues mal en Open tu
perds tes deux parties d'affilée bon là
normalement tu joues quelqu'un de
beaucoup moins fort que toi et tu peux
te refaire bon bah là tu perds de partie
d'acide tu joues Magnus quoi
c'est pas la même du tout c'est pas la
même du tout
donc avoir nul probable j'imagine quand
même mais peut-être même les noirs sont
sont déjà pas mal
mettre le frein et trouver comment
conclure non
peut-être manger et je tourne
essayer un truc comme ça sachant qu'il y
a un bon petit brochette là voir tu
prends je prends du cavalier mais c'est
vrai qu'on a l'impression que les Blancs
un peu de mal à bouger quand même parce
que bon qui avait des bouge pas à cause
de caballer prend un croix
E3 mais j'ai peur que il tourne un carré
en dessin qui est pas mal un jour il
peut se retrouver en B6 à 4 B6 à 4
bon alors après évidemment c'est
abaisser FGH contrat GH
ça va être difficile de la perdre
normalement mais bon on est arrivé et
puis en plus Wesley ça le dérange pas
tant qu'il a aucun risque en fait on dit
souvent que c'est un chargeur qui joue
pas la nul en fait c'est un joueur qui
joue d'abord pour ne pas perdre mais
après il joue beaucoup pour le gain dès
qu'il a une micro chance c'est juste il
déteste beaucoup plus perdre que gagner
lui fait plaisir c'est fait partie des
joueurs comme petrocian bon
niveau bien moindre comme moi la
victoire fait pas du tout autant plaisir
que la défaite apporte du plaisir et du
coup voilà il veut d'abord jouer pour ne
pas perdre mais celle-là il va pas la
perdre
et du coup il peut la gagner donc même
si c'est important il va tenter
[Musique]
une idée dans le sens que on a chacun
plus de place noir et que généralement
c'est finalement mais des pions sur la
couleur inverse pour essayer de de
contrôler les quasiment la couleur
adversaire en fait ici
on voit que les blancs des pions B2 et
C3 sur quasiment avec le foot casse noir
donc tu as parlé de ça et ça mais j'aime
beaucoup aussi l'idée de pousser le pion
jusqu'en A4
est-ce que tu joues à trois sur horrible
avec les blancs de la 3 mais c'est aussi
encore plus horrible de laisser faire à
4 à 3 donc
gagner des pions
et si tu me fais à trois je m'incavelais
là et puis ben tu as une structure
vraiment dégueulasse et en plus des
sacrifices en A3 qui commence un petit
peu à sauver donc
en fait en tout cas je pense qu'il y a
un léger pressing pour le noir si elle
est blanc n'arrive pas c'est souvent il
y a un bail out les prochains coups
peuvent être décisif parce que tu tu vas
savoir si tu vas souffrir pour l'entrée
longtemps ou si tu fais nulle tout de
suite
la lettre de cas de figure sont
clairement plausibles et c'est pour ça
qu'arian je pense va passer beaucoup de
temps à voir s'il a une nulle forcée
et si elle existe clairement le niveau
pour la trouver mais si elle n'existe
pas à savoir que tu vas souffrir pendant
des heures contre un des meilleurs
techniciens de la planète qui veut
vraiment pas te rater parce que parce
que ça vaut trois points la victoire bon
c'est un psychologiquement c'est super
dur quoi
donc après c'est peut-être aussi moi je
connais pas du tout la nature mais c'est
peut-être une partie importante pour la
théorie parce que Ariane qui rentre dans
mes Marshall et qui se retrouvent pas
très bien c'est peut-être qui s'est pris
un truc qui n'était pas au courant quand
même donc avoir checker les joueurs
joueuses de 4 5 il a peut-être important
c'est vrai que là on est au 20e coup
avec bon c'est il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de théories la cave des pensées une
demi-heure à la pendule donc peut-être
que il y a un truc qui et on prend la
noire tous les jours dans la position
donc a priori c'est pris un coup qui qui
connaissait pas auquel il a mal réagi
en fait maintenant
qu'elle a commencé à réfléchir
premier coup
où il a réfléchi en fait
le reste c'est quand même plus ou moins
rapide quoi
ok bon ok alors
on va aller voir alors un filou contre
une française avec un homme premier de
un monde non pas du tout
donc la française qui a quand même
remise au coup du jour
c'est marrant
bonne nuit
je crois que ça se passe pas du tout
bien pour
on va juste la jauge qui a l'air d'aimer
beaucoup les Noirs alors
moi je me méfierai de la jauge dans une
position assez complète parce que la
profondeur est probablement moins que
que celle avec laquelle ils analyses
leur
nouveauté mais donc il faut voir parce
qu'il a pas beaucoup réfléchi frérot
après est-ce que c'est le style à
pouvoir bluffer moi je le connais pas
c'est encore est-ce que comme elle est
bonne tu sais que la banane quand il a
encore deux heures à la pendule il peut
il peut être out of the book depuis du
coup justice Blitz et puis il est
content et il bluff quoi mais là on se
retrouvait mal d'après la jauge avec les
Blancs alors que tu as encore une heure
45 à la pendule dans une position aussi
complexe
c'est chelou
donc
ça se trouve ce coup de cavalier B5 qui
est déjà à l'air ultra naturel qui a été
joué après combien de temps de réflexion
tu sais
qui a été 3 minutes 45
c'est pas beaucoup quand même
donc après il peut confondre aussi parce
que c'est peut-être ça faut mettre
l'autre cavalier ou j'en sais rien ou
dans une variante il faut mettre ce
cavalier mais pas ici enfin parfois on
confond aussi la variante mais en tout
cas si tu connais pas du tout la
position je vais réfléchis pas trois
minutes pour jouer un coup comme ça non
c'est clair puis d'ailleurs tu vas faire
en fait je crois qu'il y a pas de cas où
tu connais pas de la position parce que
tu rentres pas là-dedans
ouais donc ça ça c'est vraiment signe
tomber vite si tu connais quoi ah oui tu
joues pas un coup de route
donc bon
on parle à fourchette
et il est quand même venu en C7 pour
dire OK et il est revenu
mais le roi noir maintenant on va être
obligé d'être au centre donc on voit
maintenant où est-ce que les gens font
partie on a du contrôle jeu sur le roi
parce que là
on voit la jauge mais si on oublie la
jauge l'espace d'un instant les Noirs
ont de plus ils ont pris B2 ils ont pris
à deux donc plus mais le roi noir
durablement ensemble des requêtes alors
le roi blanc pour l'instant il fait pas
trop le malin non plus mais lui il sera
en plus ou moins sécurité en G1 voir
même en H1 plus tard et la dame en a
deux ok pour l'instant elle est pas
captuable mais même pas très bien non
plus quoi donc effectivement
[Musique]
concrète une position tellement concrète
qu'il faut faire
c'est difficile de juger sur des
facteurs comme ça purement abstrait
purement positionnel mais a priori il y
a clairement beaucoup de jeux pour les
blancs après est-ce que ça compense de
pions est-ce que ça compense du point de
vue de l'ordinateur est-ce que ça compte
pas du point de vue humain aussi pas la
même chose parce que si le chemin vers
l'avantage pour les noirs et tellement
étroit que même Kawana ne peut pas le
trouver c'est pas la même que s'il est
suffisamment large
donc je sais pas mais position ultra
complète qui correspond aux deux joueurs
Cavana carvana est calcule tellement
bien quand il a du temps en tout cas
quand il y a du temps est calcule
tellement bien que
qui sait être
ultra concret et puis bon bah filou
firou c'est le génie donc
et donc là ouais
donc ça c'est très bien on voit aussi
des idées
alors enfermement de dames je sais
jamais parce que sur dame C3 il y aura
toujours un problème avec de foot B4
pour me laisser tourner ça va pas bien
se passer du tout il y aura juste ouais
ça c'est clair
rock au prochain coup dès que c'est
ouais mais en fait c'est ça qui va
essayer parce que les Noirs ont deux
pions plus la dame elle est elle est
elle s'est perdue en à deux le temps
qu'elle revienne ça va être compliqué au
revoir la jauge je crois que je préfère
les blancs je préfère prendre les blancs
en tout cas si on me laisse au choix et
même peut-être même en reconnaissant la
jauge j'ai peut-être quand même envie de
prendre les blancs parce qu'avec les
noirs avec les Noirs même si on me dit
que je suis mieux bah je sais que je
vais pas je vais pas résister du coup
quoi
je me fais mal avec les Noirs je pense
que c'est une position qui est
humainement très difficile à très
difficile à
jouer et du coup petit rock regarde la
F5 j'ai l'impression qu'il est tout
ouvert donc j'ai parlé de pions
c'est quatre ça peut arriver un cavalier
des 6 pour forcer faut prendre des 6
non c'est clair c'est clair c'est
chaud mais bon en tout cas c'est une
ouverture assez intéressante carvana qui
a dépensé une demi-heure déjà contre un
quart d'heure chez firou donc est-ce que
c'est bon peut-être
oui oui en tout cas c'est sûr c'est
grave un bon signe qu'il soit pas encore
en train de vie c'est ça
et après moi ça me fait penser juste une
dernière réflexion il y a mais je crois
que c'était Carona
des problèmes de se préparer avec des
ordinateurs à profondeur 50 etc c'est
que même quand il y a l'avantage c'est
un avantage souvent inhumain et du coup
tu te retrouves dans ce genre de
position alors là cette position précise
j'ai pas le niveau pour la juger par le
sujet du point de vue de d'un joueur à
2800 je veux dire mais
donc voilà même quand la jauge te donne
un avantage bon bah si si tu vas mal
jouer parce que elle est trop difficile
pour un 2800 ça sert à rien quoi alors
car il prend des trois donc sa force
d'apprendre parce qu'il y avait toujours
ce fou B4
donc d'un point de 3 donc là on va alors
concrètement
[Musique]
j'aime pas la position mais ouais en
fait humainement ça a l'air très dur
pour les mains mais il y a quand même
deux pions et le roi qui est au centre
et la paire de fou aussi
mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur une
proposition malhonnête comme dame C4
[Musique]
peut-être que les Blancs un peu plus de
choix c'est mon impression mais enfin
selon le coup de noir évidemment mais
a priori il y a pas beaucoup de bons
coups
et après petit rock je menace déjà F5
mais associé des coups comme damset 3 il
menace pour ça
enfin
il peut y avoir des galets princesse qui
avait les princesses ce genre de enfin
il peut y avoir 1000 trucs quoi
hyper interdit à suivre on n'a pas fait
des petits pronos
contre 12 autographes 2 3 4 5 6 ok bon
je dirais pas du tout
non je sais pas du tout
alors je vais prendre un risque mais je
pense qu'il y a plus de chance une pire
une fille du Nord
je pense que c'est sûr mais je pense que
avec avec tous les quatre échecs et C3
c'est pas bête mais bon
[Musique]
j'ai bien fait de pleurer va j'en sais
rien j'en ai aucune idée alors qu'en
fait je connais la position
[Rires]
comme ça il y a pas longtemps mais ah
mais là je suis bête
à trouver mais il y a une partie et en
tournoi c'était qui encore qui jouait il
y a une partie comme ça je parlais de la
fameuse partie entre
[Musique]
quand même un truc
et bonne forest qui s'était joué au
je sais plus je crois que c'était au
style et il y avait une lampe un peu de
même style bon elle est bien plus longue
partir en même temps noir
quasiment pareil mais du coup bon là ils
sont là ils sont tranquilles là
ouais non mais qui se passe un truc
quand même pas totalement intuitif c'est
que depuis trois coups les blancs
peuvent faire faut prendre un 6 et
rendre le pion aussi s'isoler et quand
même un truc je sais pas que emballage
je crois que je l'aurais fait à tempo en
me disant que enfin j'aurais pas pu
résister mais en fait le pion aussi et
pas mal parce qu'il contrôle la case de
5 et la Casa F5 sur lesquelles les
cavaliers blancs veulent aller un jour
en tout cas donc c'est très intéressant
ce concept parce que d'habitude on veut
garder le moins d'îlots possible donc là
les Noirs ont deux îlots 3 pions à la
dame trois pions on a le droit alors
qu'après faut prendre un 6 il y a trois
îlots et un pion isolé donc mais c'est
très intéressant de voir que
le continuellement les blancs refusent
de prendre ici c'est LA Noire même
limite un site la cavaluation qui
attaque le fou je trouve ça
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant comme
concept mais c'est vrai que ce pion ici
il est fort
il contrôle la case de 5 à 5 il peut pas
facilement être attaquer et c'est pas du
tout évident en tout cas pour une chose
comme moi je sais pas si tu vois toi toi
tu aurais jamais joué pas
ça m'a un peu
jean-luciner
j'étais totalement gagnante j'ai
refaitais la nuit et j'ai perdu mais
j'ai joué ça aussi mais donc oui oui le
pion le combo de pion isolé doublé 5 à 6
on l'aime bien ouais ouais donc là bon
il y a eu 6
les Blancs ont craqué
après ce que j'ai dit sur le plan 6
c'est vrai tant qu'il y a beaucoup de
pièces c'est sinon il peut il peut
vraiment être faible si
là il est bien parce que il gène les
deux cavaliers blancs mais bon par
exemple en finale de Tours en finale de
roi même on peut regretter d'avoir un
avoir un peu isolé d'ailleurs ici est-ce
que je peux pas essayer de faire un truc
de style alors moi je vois à 6 par
exemple moi cavalier B5 etc on sait
jamais puis des fois
et surtout de 1 et ben écoute je vais te
faire un goût qui qui est pas forcément
conseillé
quand un joueur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu vas me faire en fait
bon généralement c'est normal quand un
joueur en fait
quand un joueur essaie de contester la
colonne et en fait les échange pas
partir c'est pas forcément un bon coup
pas parce que
les blancs de la colonne des d'accord et
on veut pas du tout laisser la colonne à
l'adversaire par contre Ben la colonne D
j'ai l'impression qu'on fait pas grand
chose avec les Blancs et donc moi j'ai
envie de te dire ben écoute très bien tu
l'as gagné et moi je vais faire la fac
de minorité
qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette idée
d'essayer de faire un truc de type G5
minorité rapidement vous avez bon
papillon contre 4 en fait vous allez
pousser des pions pour essayer de créer
les faiblesses chez les pions de
l'adversaire donc c'est un
dire c'est un c'est quelque chose qui
est qui est très très connu très
et assez fort
[Musique]
mais j'aime bien en plus après j'ai 5 il
peut aussi avoir des caméras 4 sur leur
idée et faut pas oublier non plus
la majorité c'est les blancs va avoir
beaucoup de mal à pousser la majorité de
pion monsieur normalement on essaie de
se créer un pion passé on est en finale
on veut se créer un pion passé pour
faire dames pour ce créature passer il
faut pousser notre majorité de pions
donc là avec les blancs sur un échec est
vide enfin si on gardait que les pions
on enlève toutes les pièces on joue F4
puis F5 le Pione F devient candidat puis
ensuite on fait chacun G5 on se crée un
pion passé sauf que là on va jamais
réussir à court terme en tout cas à
jouer à jouer à F4 F5 à plus la majorité
et notamment le pur réussi si j'aime
bien là-dedans mais peut-être que les
noirs de l'autre côté ils peuvent plus
le faire c'est 5 B5 alors c'est 7 donc
du coup peut-être le remplissage et la
tour en cabine du coup plus quand j'ai 8
médecins je sais pas j'ai l'impression
que c'est des Noirs qui sont du bon côté
de l'égalité alors après on peut quand
même faire des efforts pour la perdre
avec le blanc mais
mais c'est vrai que parfois bouger quoi
c'est pas très mobile ta majorité elle
est patrimobile et dès que tu bouges un
pion tu as fait bis celui-là tu donnes
des cases et donc avant de pousser un
peu faut être sûr et même qu'on peut
lundi tout à l'heure avec le pion en F7
à la place je pourrais essayer de faire
du H3 F4 G4 ça peut aller très vite je
pense pour cette position
[Musique]
je mets un cavalier en F4 et tu vas être
fait toute la partie et mes deux pions
bloquent les quatre pions
donc mathématiquement je crois que ça
marche pas
j'ai trois contre deux ici free que je
vais pousser au fur et à mesure
je pense mais bon vu qu'on parlait de
pronostics je pronostic quand même une
nul
[Musique]
ça marche je te fais confiance
donc
Mamadou nul pour moi
[Musique]
alors est-ce que tu veux on donne les
résultats 100g
[Musique]
elle est magnifique
ok bon de toute façon je pense que là
[Musique]
on va déterminer Paris
ouais ouais
allez je vais mettre nul quand même
si vous voulez gagner de l'argent sur
les siestes vous me faites confiance à
moi
je suis assez mauvais généralement
alors celle-ci
[Musique]
elle va me coûter parce que je vais
faire parler
le chauvinisme à la place de la raison
mais donc une pièce sur une pièce sur
Furon
[Musique]
salut à tous sans sur le chat un pas de
métal lucopat l'approche de Baki
[Musique]
je crois qu'il avait on l'a déjà salué
en tout cas bonjour à tous et Antoine
n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à nous à vos questions
également
faites-vous plaisir sur notre chat
sniper Michel sniper
des questions sur quoi que ce soit si
vous voulez voir les parties en priorité
des choses voilà mais n'hésitez pas en
tout cas
rebondissement quelconque quelque part
aussi à saluer aussi nos amis qui sont
sur Youtube
qui nous regardent en ce moment même
donc j'ai vu David avec des questions si
on avait des astuces
pour partager à partager pardon pour
penser plusieurs coups à l'avance
est-ce que tu as des astuces pour le
calcul le chat
on peut faire des petits jeux alors moi
outre s'entraîner on peut faire des
petits jeux comme jouer aux échecs avec
un coup de décalage je sais pas si tu as
déjà fait ça ça prend un peu de temps
pour comprendre comment ça se passe mais
en gros à ça joue à une nouvelle life
tu te dis ton premier coup appuies sur
la pendule mettez le joues pas je te dis
E4 j'appuie là tu me dis E5 tu appuie là
je te dis cavalier F3 et en disant
qu'elle avait froid je joue mon premier
coup donc je joue au 4 donc il y a
toujours un coup de décalage donc en
fait ça te force
et après la pendule elle marche
normalement donc en fait c'est comme une
partie normale sauf que tu as un coup à
l'avance quoi donc ça par exemple c'est
un petit entraînement sympa
que je fais parfois maintenant je fais
plus j'ai raté les courante là mais que
je faisais en club voilà avec les jeunes
c'est marrant c'est un bon entraînement
quoi donc c'est toujours aux échecs avec
un coup à la table
donc ce genre de petit jeu alors après
il faut pas non plus trop se prendre la
tête c'est en progression de manière
générale on progresse à l'aveugle et
qu'on progresse on calcule voilà donc
cette notion de voir des coups à
l'avance
ah c'est juste que tu fais des exercices
sans volonté spécifique entraîner cette
capacité tu l'entraîneras en fait ouais
et en fait moi j'avais un même exercice
mais un petit peu un petit peu différent
en fait je l'ai souvent quand j'étais au
club d'ailleurs que dans le fond ça
marche pas mal et ben tu les fais jouer
l'aveugle mais en fait
ce que tu fais c'est que bon il y a
sorti qui arrive pas à la veuve tu vois
un joueur qui a qui a 1100 élo je ne
partirai en tir à la haute
si tu veux sur sur cahier par exemple
trois ou quatre coups d'accord et tous
les trois ou quatre coups il vient jouer
les coups sur le chéquier et regarder la
position pendant genre 30 secondes et tu
reparte un soir
et là tu refais des coups et après tu
reviens les jouets tu vois et pendant
trois quatre coups tu penses à la potion
dans ta tête que tu viens ce que tu as
vu il y a 30 secondes et tu rejoues
alors après si trois quatre coups
peut-être que je peux le faire en moins
tu arrives pas j'ai 1 2 coups de force à
imaginer la bonne position et c'est
aussi un exercice qui est
intéressant pour apprendre les cases
pour pour bien viser les déchets pour
réussir à calculer
un petit peu sans voir l'échiquier donc
c'est des astuces qui sont en tout cas
intéressants pour le jeu à la vague
spécifiquement j'avais écrit un article
sur jazz 24
sur je crois que je l'avais écrit qu'en
français d'ailleurs celui-là je l'avais
pas traduit en anglais mais donc si vous
tapez exercer son traitement jeux à
l'aveugle chaise 24 priori vous allez
tomber dessus donc j'ai fait plein
d'exercices selon le niveau donc des
exercices adaptés au niveau 1000
exercices adapté niveau grand maître
un pour s'entraîner spécifiquement
donc vous pouvez trouver
des petits jeux des maths en deux avec
peu de pièces à résoudre des exercices
d'ouverture des
Jeux il y a plein de choses mais après
encore une fois avoir ce que tu disais
sur un 1100 qui peut pas jouer une
partie entière à la balle c'est vrai et
en revanche un grand maître qui peut
aucun 1100 ne peut et aucun grand maître
ne peut pas quoi c'est
plutôt tous les grands mètres pub en
français mais donc voilà c'est c'est pas
parce que il y a une mémoire spécifique
je sais pas quoi que les grands maîtres
auraient un bon spécial non c'est parce
que quand tu as passé des milliers
d'heures à t'entraîner aux échecs ma
maman tu peux jouer des parties à
l'aveugle et en revanche avant d'avoir
passé ces milliers d'heures c'est juste
pas possible c'est donc c'est pas une
mémoire spécifique une qualité
spécifique c'est juste que tout le monde
peut partir d'un certain nombre d'heures
d'entraînement quoi
alors mince cavalier ce mauvais coup
pourquoi ça serait mauvais
ça a l'air quand même assez naturel
mais bon après encore une fois faut pas
trop faire confiance à leur ditescom
ce joueur là ils ont des des PC
d'analyse qui sont juste ouais mais
alors là on est plus on est plus dans la
préparé
même face à l'air pas mal
reposer droit tu peux tu peux te faire
mater quand même mais en finale
en tout cas c'est concret prise et là
c'est chaud vraiment c'est une partie
parce que
c'est hyper compliqué enfin le roi noir
il est il est vraiment ensemble
l'échiquier Pirou il va tout faire pour
l'ouvrir
mais bon
avec du temps la pendule c'est un des
meilleurs calculateurs
et compagnie mais en pertinente
il est juste excellent quand il a du
temps à la pendule pour calculer c'est
une machine c'est une machine
donc
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut aller voir
un peu surpris de chez toi
alors on a eu on a eu le tour
on avait dit donc moi j'avais dit à 6
pour comparer bon lui il fait 5 directs
aussi qui contrôle à la case la case
j'aurais jamais réussi parce que j'ai
besoin de contrôler quelqu'un enfin
ici donc
en plus il y a une idée
très très concrète de en plus de jouer
assise B5 c'est 4 etc
ça peut être relou
les Blancs n'ont plus la casse de 5 mais
les Noirs ont la case de 4
définitivement
parce que je peux pas rester comme ça
indéfiniment je peux pas tester et faire
tout ce que tu veux non plus donc là il
y a deux coups soit on vient ici soit on
vient ici
sur cavalier c'est 6 j'imagine qu'il
faut commencer à calculer du coup comme
5 aussi
et
ma belle loi
échec handicap
é donc on va venir en bien au cas où
et là mon cavalier va où sortir
j'imagine si tu prends du cavalier c'est
plutôt
et après c'est le bazar tout d'un coup
ça devient
de nouvelles positions ou chaque camp a
maintenant de son passé l'allum majorité
pour chacun
c'est compliqué
à t'en trouver donc
[Musique]
sinon avec une possibilité
aussi mais si je fais un coup comme je
te rends pas
[Musique]
mal hein
donc ça c'est concret là encore une fois
on avait dit nuls tous les deux
non j'avais mis
c'est vrai
ok bon quand on regarde alors
est-ce que tu as quelque chose
qu'on a pas vu
mais ça mérite quand même sûrement
on s'est arrêté là petit rock et elle a
juste fou des sept avec le noir
cavaliers à 3
alors on est plus habitués à la manœuvre
cavaler des deux Torin cavalier F1
cavaliers 3 ou parfois plus rarement
cavaluer trois parce que là en plus
c'est un peu la case du fou mais donc on
peut aller en trois par là mais on peut
aussi tout à fait à l'air en A3 en E3
via à 3 puis c'est deux puis trois
donc ça c'est des manœuvres qui arrivent
c'est souvent même par ces quatre aussi
quand c'est le fou qui en ces deux par
exemple et donc ce cavalier A3 dans
l'italien il est moins fréquent que le
cavalier de 2 évidemment mais il arrive
il arrive très souvent
en revanche bon moi qui joue pas
j'ai pas beaucoup de connaissances mais
je crois pas me rappeler d'un cavalier à
3 avec le fou encore en C5 justement je
je moi je l'ai vu il y a pas longtemps
[Musique]
alors c'est un souvenir que j'ai dans ma
tête c'est un truc que j'ai vu commenter
je me souviens plus du tout
non mais en fait
mais je sais pas qui est-ce que j'ai des
parties dans la base
[Musique]
les blancs gagnent la paire de fou mais
voilà ce genre de pion détruite les
Noirs regrette maintenant d'avoir joué à
5 parce que le pion B7 est sur une
colonne vertes et le pouce en baissier
ça me manque un peu de souplesse mais
arrive et les Noirs ne veulent pas jouer
ne veulent pas jouer P6 donc tourbé vite
joint
alors après ça a pas l'air non plus
totalement rotation
avec mes yeux en tout cas mais ok on
préfère le pire on baisser ça c'est sûr
et donc faut baisser peut-être un des
problèmes sur un B6 ça coûte fou B7
[Musique]
on va regarder
parce que en fait il y a une menace
c'est ça que tu veux dire
un coup comme ça
mais en fait peut-être que j'ai de la
chance
dans
[Musique]
ce que j'ai sélectionné
en fait quand on parle d'affaiblissement
le cas c'est toujours très abstrait oui
monsieur ça fait Billie les cases
blanches bon bah là en deux coups c'est
très concret tu perds une pièce sur case
blanche parce que tu te fais attaquer
sur quelqu'un
donc voilà
[Musique]
pas seulement ça en positionnement c'est
très nécessaire tactiquement sur moi
alors là il y a aussi un truc qu'on peut
regarder parce qu'on vient de voir
ça
et je me dis bon bah écoute mais le
problème c'est que j'ai plus beaucoup de
pièces quand même
B2 qui arrive
alors après faut toujours faire gaffe
[Musique]
tu vois que tu peux détruire le rock
tu vois dans ma chambre
après je comprends je comprends que le
noir sont mieux mais je vais venir
en fait
on comprend que on comprend que ça doit
pas marcher mais juste avec les Noirs tu
peux pas te permettre de
m'entourer ton nom sur la feuille de
parti tu peux te faire mater et il y a
des cas où ça se passe mal quoi
[Musique]
et là il y a plein de petites menaces
qui s'ajoutent à la pollution parce que
on parle tout à l'heure
pour dévier la dame en fait de la
défense du cabane etc mais en plus de la
fourchette en dessin je signe menace de
manger aussi
et le fou servir aussi si je prends des
cinq donc vous prends un deux paires
et en plus
mais bon si c'est bon
[Rires]
moi j'ai pas de chance
pas mal
après j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire au
combo faut prendre un deux cavalier à 7
mais après c'est concret on a mangé un
pion si je peux jouer aussi derrière
mais
bon je sais pas
du coup c'est peut-être pas assez dure
en tout cas tu dois passer un peu de
temps à vérifier ce qui se passe dessus
quand même
pas trop hein ce qu'il fait
je voyais pas la suite
[Musique]
prise dans ma carte pour prendre
on attaque le calibé saint qu'on menace
de prendre 5
ça fait beaucoup de choses
ouais ouais bon en tout cas en tout cas
il y a des trucs mais
c'est pas parti avec son fond à deux ah
donc faut j'ai quatre très logique pour
menacer à tout moment de prendre un
froid et en tout cas
jamais se prendre de prendre 5 enfin
faut prendre ceci espion prendre 5 qu'on
avait mentionné
par exemple la prise de type pour manger
là d'accord et ben maintenant ce sera
plus tout possible avec le point je
garde parce que je suis cloué et à tout
moment je mange je mange une Canada
comment est-ce qu'on joue ici
[Musique]
avec
un
plan sur un truc marrant moi je pense
qu'on prend celle-ci mais si on joue un
coup nul comme je sais pas tout rien
enfin
donc faut prendre et si on fait je
prends froid pour pas ouais que ce soit
mais juste c'était juste des points
froid j'ai 5 la fameuse structure qu'on
a reventionné avec
un devinter Casablanca quoi
avec le fou j'ai froid qui jouera plus
jamais quoi
[Musique]
et après ce qui est marrant c'est que
non vas-y il faut prendre ceci
non ou alors peut-être H3 d'abord est-ce
que H3 est un con
en fait ce que je voulais montrer c'est
que sur X5
et il peut y avoir la même idée couleur
verte tu vois sur X5 tu fais un
C6 tu reprends bébé il faut prendre M6
et j'ai 4
ans
fermés c'est un thème donc la partie on
la rappelle après référence c'était à
winter qui est blanc contre capable en
cas et je crois qu'il a pris un petit
coup de froid
une différence de volume assez
considérable on entend le chat très
clairement et tout semble grommeler
derrière sa moustache
non mais je sais pas je suis peut-être
plus proche du micro que tout devant moi
là je suis en train de le manger
[Musique]
ça c'était grosmenage s'il te plaît
je pense que mon micro il a il a fait
son temps
je vais baisser un peu mon micro
pour équilibrer les sons il m'a fait un
tuto et mais hier il est tard
désolé j'ai oublié j'ai oublié
j'ai oublié et donc
j'ai une journée hier
[Musique]
quasiment et je suis rentré à la maison
voilà fatigué et ce matin j'ai eu des
cours et bon
c'est une bonne fatigue ça va
je viens de changer un peu ce que c'est
c'est mieux ou pas si elle voulait parce
que j'essaie de faire des petits tests
tu te lèves à mon niveau s'il te plaît
mais tu me baises
[Musique]
mais moi je peux pas je peux plus là
2018 déjà c'est trop dur
[Musique]
face à la risque est quand même
pas trop le malin non plus
je m'en fous
et
5 ouais mais je prends
tu es content là tu es content là
[Musique]
l'initiative il va pas l'attaque non
c'est intéressant en vrai
OK
[Rires]
en tout cas vous voyez que c'est
compliqué il y a plein plein de choses
je peux aussi sinon commencer par faut
prendre
mais
je comprends pas pourquoi la jauge le
moufte pas plus que ça alors non tu peux
prendre bien quand même parce que là je
te reprends bébé c'est grave mais tu
peux prendre un bain
et surtout reprendre bien prendre le 5
mais ça a quand même l'air terrible
au mieux au mieux pas terrible
parce qu'en fait je pense à cette
position
j'ai toujours ça intermédiaire et je
pense que c'est
pas sûr parce que je te joue pas tomber
ça je jouerai enfin là-bas
celle-là je te la joue je te la joue
ouais
[Musique]
2 et ensuite tomber seulement quand ça
gagne je te le jure
c'est un peu trop ingénieur je crois
ouais non c'est vrai
après peut-être c'est nul mais les
blancs sont beaucoup mieux des blancs
qui jouent comme regagner j'ai ça ça a
priori je vais réussir à manger quelque
part donc on a dit plutôt de team top 3
bernabar
et le chaos des complications
[Musique]
un jour
c'est la partie
en tout cas
je pense que si un duo s'est trompé
c'est pas nous deux c'est Google je vois
pas d'autres explications
[Musique]
significatif mais non on va pouvoir si
le fou peut dominical
du coup le 7 pour manger des six
le piano
si ça mange pas des 6 c'est le fou peut
se faire capturer quoi
[Musique]
il y a pas de raison que les blancs
soient pas mieux avec un plomb de plus
tu vois c'est à peu près plus ou moins
égal mais j'ai l'impression
donc les blancs pour deux résultats a
priorius et pas bien je suis triste donc
regardons autre chose
on a parlé de ce piond qui pouvait être
fort alors les Noirs non plus leur paire
de fou mais ça aurait réussi à le dessin
c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle donc
l'avez vu e5f6 mais pas encore les
changements à 5
ok donc vous voyez c'est vraiment le
combat depuis le début on vous l'avait
dit
[Musique]
c'est la même manière qu'on met
d'habitude les tours sur des colonnes
ouvertes mais les fous sur des
diagonales ouvertes là pour l'instant
elle est fermée mais elle peut s'ouvrir
à tout moment c'est à dire si les pions
arrivent en C5 en D4 un lépion seront
extraordinairement bien placé et le fou
aussi donc en attendant faut baissez en
contrôle bien le plan C6 et les blancs
doivent surveiller des quatre tu évites
de ces 5 ou l'inverse d'ailleurs donc on
peut pas faire du coup ça prive les
pièces blanches d'une certaine marge de
manœuvre là le genre on doit avoir une
torrentin parce que sinon c'est un tour
ça va ailleurs des quatre ça peut
pousser très vite c'est l'option d’est
passé donc structurellement les noirs
sont beaucoup mieux avec un pion déjà
passé puis en plus la pincée protégée
donc
les pions blancs ils sont pas du tout
fait la sang un peu sur la case de
départ
mais pour l'instant les pièces blanches
sont plus centralisées mais le blanc
doivent transformer cet avantage de
pièces plus active comme ça je peux
mieux centraliser en quelque chose de
concret parce que d'ici trois quatre
coups si les pièces noires arrivent à
s'activer ou à s'échanger contre la
pièce blanche ce qui restera c'est le
problème structurel de blanc donc c'est
aguerri de trouver de l'activité là
d'ailleurs on voit la différence de
temps la pendule qui commence à
parler sérieusement 40 minutes de moins
c'est 50 minutes de moins c'est beaucoup
donc
bonne chance bonne petite chance pour
Naka quand même
à prendre la paire de fou au noir c'est
aussi une bonne chose oui alors ça oui
la même position avec un four en GSM
c'est juste gagnant
là c'est si je devais remettre une pièce
peut-être plus team Naka tu vois même si
ok guéri quand
quand il faut pas perdre il se faire
aussi mais je trouve c'est difficile à
jouer pour pour les blancs enfin c'est
vraiment au blanc de construire quelque
chose
il a joué il a joué à 4 d'ailleurs
qu'un coup responsable comme on les
appelle
une bêtise
partage on est là pour ça
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien un cas mais c'est pas
bizarre ben écoute non il y en a qu'à
c'est un super joueur c'est un prénom
streamer
c'est une personnalité donc
qui s'est bien amélioré quand même je me
rappelle première fois que j'ai vu la
casse Top 16 à l'époque 2009 je crois et
jouer avec l'équipe
il avait fait un sport monstrueux genre
10 et demi sur 11 un médecin toutes ces
parties en juin 4 5 d'un machin alors il
était donc envoyé le talent fou mais il
était insupportable imbuvable quoi
c'était vraiment bon j'ai pas employé de
moi trop vulgaire mais c'était c'était
un con on va dire
mais et même son comportement sur
l'échiquier a beaucoup pu choqué ou
gêner des joueurs à l'époque quoi mais
il s'est bien amélioré c'est devenu en
plus d'un un meilleur humain alors après
il partait loin mais mais clairement et
puis évidemment après pour qui aime le
jeu d'échec elles sont tous ces grands
streamers on est obligé de leur être
reconnaissante en tout cas à quoi c'est
tellement à l'apport de Naka pour le jeu
de chat qui est tellement énorme
tellement considérable que
c'est difficile de pas lire connaître au
moins ça quoi
après après ouais si c'était si je
devais passer une soirée avec un devoir
de tournoi pas sûr que je choisisse
d'accord
[Musique]
[Rires]
ici en termes d'intérêt je pense chez
vous c'est celui dont je me sens le plus
proche
firou pas du tout Fabi
à chaque fois que je l'entends parler il
est
juste sage intelligent respectueux
[Musique]
on peut parler on peut parler de mode de
Paris mais sinon je crois que c'est un
peu limité mais point commun
Maxime aussi dans ce cas là c'est un an
de warnience il y a des
sur la droite cité des absents il y a
vraiment des gens très intéressants
humainement respectueux très accessible
dans le top échiquier
mais après dans ce tournoi je crois que
Fabi c'est celui que je préfère en tout
cas
je connais pas toi tu devais faire une
soirée
un compagnon de picole je te conseille
même
[Rires]
[Musique]
à ce moment-là
en fait je sais pas moi les mêmes
raisons que moi
en fait je sais pas c'est vrai que bon
Google
la caméra c'est un super streamer etc
mais bon en heads je sais pas
tu arrives il a la hyper sympa
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps
toute première joueuse à avoir Dieu
quitté l'Iran pour avoir joué sans voile
oui d'ailleurs
[Musique]
il y en a est-ce que tu fais partie du
fan club officiel de la sagla la société
des adorateurs d'Algérie
pour cette formation
parce que il y a vraiment un truc dans
ta personnalité dans sa personnalité qui
t'attire
alors bon sinon parlons un peu de sa
partie quand même
il a toujours pas ok et il y aura plus
de mal à le faire maintenant
[Musique]
parce que
si au 5 arrive et ça va arriver enfin de
toute façon c'est F6 téléphone le coup 5
mais si ça arrive en fait c'est le noir
qui vont avoir les pions de plus et le
compensation quoi donc
ouais ouais je crois que le perroquet
comme quoi le petit allié raisin il a
encore des choses à apprendre un
choupinou tu auras avant le 15e coup la
prochaine fois s'il te plaît
il avait le temps d'attaquer mais
j'imagine que si
quelque chose qui l'embêtait
sur le long terme
[Musique]
parce qu'il y a déjà enfin
matériellement c'est des blancs sont
totalement foutus il y a d'options de
moins et le plan des 6 dans toutes les
finales ou quoi il tombe donc la seule
question c'est est-ce que le bon peuvent
avoir du jeu et on envoie plus là du jeu
enfin on est en train de se demander
est-ce que c'est LA Noire qui vont jouer
de tour à 8 au 5 et matin mais en fait
faut se rappeler
donc ils ont juste à pas se faire mater
pour être gagnant
donc c'est pas du tout
situation convenable alors après
peut-être qu'il y a des idées auxquelles
on pense pas genre mais je vois pas
sans que ça a l'air con
bref deux enfin un entourage ou pas mais
c'est pas ça a l'air à trois
je comprends même pas pourquoi la jauge
n'est pas beaucoup plus
noirs sont sont faibles en finale
c'est simple à faire enfin il faut quand
même préparer imaginons un
e5e
mais bon Laura même en C8
après encore une fois c'est pas noir
d'attaquer sur blanc de 3 alors après
peut-être qu'à un moment il y aura un
cas les princesses faut prendre un sac
ou Damas 5 et puis je tourne
parce que le pion des 6 bon il est aussi
intéressant
mais bon
tu récupères un pion mais bon tu en as
déjà deux mois et celui qui en plus
tu fais quoi regarde
mais en fait je sais pas mais chacun
il y a toujours un petit peu de chance
donc en général dans cette position
[Musique]
du roi si on joue avec une tour de main
c'est long je sais bien mais tu m'as dit
que le temps que le noir arrive un petit
peu à
se défaire de tout ça
j'ai beaucoup de mal à y croire après le
bon là le truc c'est qu'on joue avec
documents
c'est juste on joue une position de moi
ok
j'aime pas c'est juste pour montrer un
petit peu
aux gens
alors d'ailleurs ici
d'ailleurs je vais me faire voir donc
voilà attention il y a pas maintenant
j'ai toujours pire des cas mais Lily en
fait
et le fou qui viendrait en C6
intermédiaire même
en fait difficile
[Musique]
peut-être qu'elle va lire froide au
cours
il y a deux pions moins et j'ai du mal à
à avoir la suite l'impression que la
position de famille elle est trop simple
je peux faire plein de choses même
peut-être même peut-être royal
[Musique]
avec les Blancs je peux avoir ok je peux
pas
franchement je plus je vois la police je
pense que famille il a un gros avantage
pas
trop dur pour le moment
dur
de toi
simple
c'est simple
à voir
[Musique]
c'est pas grand chose
alors je sais 45 bon ça passe pas grand
chose
guirin Nakamura grand-chose et
[Musique]
tarif voir un petit peu en fait il s'est
passé des plans qu'on a dit avec à 5 à 4
donc l'avantage qui commence à croître
en plus c'est tellement dur en
psychologiquement tu vois quand tu as
les blancs tu te retrouves mal sans
jouer dans un truc ultra théorique c'est
je joue pour la nulle j'arrive même pas
à quoi faire de la clé blanc mais
quelque qu'est-ce que je peux faire à ce
jeu
ils ont ils ont la bonne façon
c'est de plans qu'on avait dans la parlé
de fixer les pions noirs
enfin de fixer les pions blancs sur case
noire et donc ce A5 A4 qui menace à
trois au moment qui force à trois avec
en plus des affaiblissements de case
donc maintenant le cavalier B6 qui avait
laissé quatre on avait parlé tout à
l'heure qui était vraiment utopique mais
là l'utopie devient réalité
et c'est très dur c'est très dur
cette position
cette position là
on est
ique que
penser à ça
il y avait eu tourner un ou pas je sais
plus si vous tournez encore et tu
m'avais dit oui cavalier les bêtises
pour rappeler c'est important ça c'est
vraiment un bon type ce que je vais vous
donner là vous avez des fous de même
couleur donc généralement dans les
positions dans les finales ou même
couleur mettez les pions sur la couleur
inverse de votre four pour ne pas que ça
faible déjà et pour essayer de
le fou contre le gaz noire si vous
voulez et votre et vos pions et ben vont
sur case blanche
pour en fait attaquer les pions à bien
regarder ici là les Noirs si je mets un
pion en A4 je menace à 3 à 3 qui va
attaquer la base la chaîne de pion
B bouge et ben je perds cette roi et
c'est même si je mange à 3 je perds
enregistrer droit niveau structure de
pions c'est c'est dégueulasse donc en
fait dès qu'on peut y avoir un A4 il va
falloir faire à 3 et maintenant j'ai
tout de pions sur case blanche donc moi
je suis content
et les blancs on va avoir tous les pions
sur case noir avec le foot casse noir et
là pour le coup de 1 le fou de cases
noires des blancs
sera moins actif que le trou noir parce
que tout on vient défendre ses pions là
qui sont toujours attaqués et avec un
Cavaillon en C4 qui va dominer
complètement la structure et ben on
pourra mettre la pression et peut-être
un jour même avoir sacrifié sur les
pions pour créer et dans cette position
on avait expliqué cette idée là le rêve
de noir dans cette position ok uf-5
on a mis le roi et il y a eu à 5 puis à
4 qui menace à trois à trois des blancs
on améliore
H6 on veut se créer aussi un peu masser
de ce côté là ou c'est un G5
G4 pour continuer à fixer
les pions les pions blancs sur le cadre
noir
[Musique]
d'après la jauge ça reste plus ou moins
égal donc c'est probablement match nul
sur un jeu parfait et je sache chaque
coup les Noirs ont 20 coups pour faire
match nul et les Blancs n'ont peut-être
un ou deux quoi et ça ça sera
durablement comme ça c'est probablement
nul sur un jeu parfait mais le chemin
est très étroit et c'est ça qu'on veut
pas
par rapport au choix d'ouverture qui
jouait peut-être pour une position
tranquille voir une nulle tranquille
qu'on peut avoir plus fort qui est SOS
mais au final et bien écoute sauvé ou sa
partie
et puis bah écoute
dans une position égale j'ai envie de
dire que normalement les camions sont
plus fort que Ariane time donc on est
pas égal
personne ne fait personne ne propose nul
noir par exemple ici
c'est une finale regarde un petit peu
les Noirs ils ont toutes les pièces
entre la quatrième et la cinquième
rangée alors que les banques pas la
troisième donc les plantes ont la même
couleur que mon fou
tous les déséquilibres sont en faveur
danois n'a rien qui va chez le Blanc
je sais c'est une position plus ou moins
asymétrique où tous les micro
déséquilibres sont un faveur de noir le
meilleur fou le meilleur cavalier les
meilleurs pions la meilleure tour même
le rat blanc est pas bien parce qu'il va
se prendre G4 il y aura deux enfin
[Musique]
je suis d'accord mais je vais peut-être
envie de le retarder un petit peu alors
je sais pas si c'est bien ou pas parce
que j'ai quatre ça a aucun des cases
noires
même si mon roi est pas rangé de mais je
me dis que quand je fais caca j'ai envie
de faire directement le combo tu vois
enfin je sais pas bon ça va bien parce
que les blancs comme ils sont mal
échanger les pièces
pourquoi je suis mal parce que j'ai
moins d'espace parce que après il faut
faire gaffe parce que en fait
perdantes avec un plan très simple et
très efficace donc c'est plus difficile
à jouer si elle est tôt mais donc
imaginons qu'elle est pour la croix
faut.3 et si les tours s'échangent les
Noirs vont faire eux aussi froides
et tous s'écroule quoi donc
[Musique]
mais j'ai quatre tours 5 tours de 5 et
on fait quoi on donne la colonne des on
laisse leur avenir de 5 parce que si on
prend pas la tour on va bouger il y aura
quand même un dessin croisé quatre donc
c'est hyper chaud donc là ok contre
l'ordi on sait qu'on gagne jamais c'est
nul donc il fait nul mais c'est
tellement facile de se tromper
la pression psychologique du contexte
tu es moins fort
tu as pas de points
dans la cerve veut absolument me battre
enfin c'est tu te sens con parce que tu
as les blancs et tu as rien montré de
bien dans cette partie quoi c'est
horrible je passe à chaque fois que ça
t'arrive ça m'arrive souvent mais
qu'est-ce que je me sens calme quand
tu as les blancs et puis en fait tu te
fais dominer le Luxembourg et puis en
plus toujours plus fort mais contrainte
plus fort tu as envie de montrer que
même si tu perds c'est pas grave mais
juste que tu étais une chose
intéressante tu trouves des idées en
fait non là en vrai pour l'instant c'est
je peux avoir les blancs quoi toi je
veux jouer je veux 15 coups et me
retrouver mal qu'est-ce que tu es
horrible retrouver mal rapidement ça va
je sais faire mais donc c'est très dur
si la perd pas il aura le sentiment
d'une victoire ben oui non mais là déjà
avec les blancs ils rêvent il va jouer
en tout cas pour la nuit
pas parce qu'il est moins fort mais
parce que la position elle est pas bonne
donc on avait une Amélie
contre même contre Manu ça c'est
là il y a pas il y a pas un joueur il y
a pas un grand maître qui joue pas pour
le gars avec la noire
on la retrouve souvent aussi dans tout
ce qui est carotane cette structure là
notamment la carrocane avec cavale FC
c'est moi je la retrouve souvent je me
suis fait visser comme ça
donc voilà c'est c'est les positions
qu'on retrouve si vous jouez sur
l'ouverture
retenez un petit peu ce thème ce qu'on
vous montre ici ça peut aussi vous vous
servir
donc il a fait ça ça alors c'est moi
mais au moins
c'est un coup après avoir
tours
[Musique]
c'est pas la même structure
mais c'est vrai que on a pas forcément
besoin en fait de se créer ce petit pion
en dessin qui est une faiblesse la
finale de la finale de pion est nulle
non pour des cartes ici
[Musique]
non je crois pas que tu t'en fiches
après on peut essayer prison des quatre
prisons
pour les noirs
je sais pas si c'est le malin mais c'est
une idée en tout cas
mais je crois qu'elle est pas d'accord
[Rires]
bon j'ai pas calcu ce qui se passait
mais effectivement ce pion il arrive
très vite
mais j'ai pas besoin en fait je pense
avec comme tu l'as dit ici qu'elle va
les prendre tout prend aussi et si
jamais j'arrive à passer mon roi en fait
le gagner enfin ça va être une torture
donc là c'est la question c'est est-ce
que roi F1 tours 5 2 et si tu redes 5
prise prison à Détroit par exemple
c'est peut-être un match nul juste comme
ça quoi mais c'est jamais certain parce
que même c'est 5 c'est 4 4 il y a après
ça allait à certains de forteresse une
fois que tu as deux
il y a plus rien mais ok mais là on voit
par exemple c'est un tempo si le roi ne
peut pas arriver de trois c'est qu'un
3p3 et tout ce qu'on a donc
on voit voilà c'est encore match nul sur
un jeu parfait la je me le dis on lui
fait confiance dans une position assez
simple mais je parfais demande
beaucoup de précision avec le blanc
donc sinon ciel bleu là je voulais
le site rouge à Clermont assumé cette
position à l'interview après une partie
contre le saut I lose more buttawin
[Musique]
je gagne plus
je perds plus mais je gagne plus
en fait je sais pas si tu connais le
principe mais
on a aussi
ok on a en fait
des confessions
[Musique]
tu as beaucoup d'interview avant partie
après partie etc ça c'est un peu normal
par contre les compressions pendant la
partie
et ben je trouve que c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant donc je reçois en fait
souvent
sur slack dès qu'il y a une conversion
et là j'en ai une qui vient d'arriver à
l'arrivée depuis une heure mais je
l'avais pas encore fait
donc tu veux je vais la télécharger et
c'est Naka qui est venu parler
pendant le début de partie
[Musique]
et puis maintenant je vais recouper le
son de la page
c'est une très longue confession en fait
je crois que n'a qu'à prépare sa vidéo
je suis sert de sa confession pour
l'intro de sa vidéo du jour et donc
voilà en tout cas sinon mais c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai compris parce que
elle a parlé de l'introduction
logarit comme si il s'adressait à sa
chaîne Youtube et tout
alors il fait un petit point sur
l'ensemble des parties aussi pour ça que
c'était très long
sur la sienne et à ce moment là il en
était un peu au confins de la théorie
donc visiblement d'après sa son
interprétation de Mimi Daniel Guéret il
pensait que Aniche était au même
pointerai que lui et donc les deux
joueurs connaissaient bien la position
il pensait que c'était probable que ça
fait possible que ça se termine par nul
rapide mais que ça puisse durer aussi
mais voilà donc en tout cas il y avait
la confiance et puis il connaissait
encore la position à ce moment là
après il a fait le tour de toutes les
parties sur Paris il a expliqué que le
coup pour 8
à la place de coup je vais par mainus
contre Naka lui-même damage 4 donc
[Musique]
les blancs un micro avantage en micro
sans aucun risque bon bah c'est pas
c'est absolument donc Ariane connaissait
mal donc peut-être qu'il avait révisé
dommage 4 mais pas trop vite par exemple
et
au moment de la vidéo Naka pensait que
ça allait faire nulle rapide
Wesley outlet Ariane mais maintenant
depuis l'a expliqué bon bah voilà Ariane
il s'est passé ton tournoi il y a une
deux trois points par match nul donc il
prend la nul où il peut et puis il joue
sur leur maillot dedans et voilà
alors après il y avait sur gocache
contre carlsal il a parlé de cette idée
de cavalier à 3
il a dit qu'il a eu ça plein de fois en
blettes parce que hyper sa vie à jouer
des Blitz
comme il a dit lui-même il pensait que
il y a un micro avantage pour les blancs
mais faut jouer de manière hyper précise
donc le parraineux c'était que gocash ne
joue pas de manière hyper précise
jusqu'au bout
voilà en gros après les autres parties
il y a un firoga c'était marrant il
avait la même interprétation que nous
sommes sans la jauge bon on voyait la
jauge très vite qui donnait l'avantage
noir mais au moment de la vidéo
il disait que ça avait l'air plus facile
à jouer pour les blancs en gros il y a
des plans simples rock F5 C4 noir c'est
pas très bien comme ce que tu fais
donc voilà ce qu'il a dit le dessus et
sur ma médias Rohff abdos
il a dit que charia avait un micro
avantage avec le Centre d'options F3 4
dans cette finale mais rien de spécial
donc voilà et la terminée
en disant que il ferait une vidéo donc
regarde ce like ou alors si en fait pas
de vidéo c'est que il serait en train de
jouer à l'armagan parce que donc il
pensait que c'était tout à fait possible
que ça participe pas rapide ok donc
voilà une très longue très longue
confession ou ouais
respirez pas quoi
c'est juste une débiteur d'éviter
je pense que le stream du monde qu'il a
il a besoin de faire son petit saut
quand même malgré
mais c'est le problème des caméras on
s'habitue tellement vite non je rigole
je rigole
[Musique]
alors est-ce que c'est pas le moment de
faire une petite pause
reviendra dans cinq minutes
et on se voit dans un instant
on se casse ce matin
pour la petite pause la première pause
on arrive dans 5 minutes
à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
tusset.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent aussi
bien sur le site internet que sur nos
applications iOS et Android pour vivre
votre passion comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec Yoha pour
cette
alors
comment tu vas depuis tout à l'heure
j'ai entendu un gros bruit un moment
qu'est-ce que c'était
parce que
je me suis pris les pieds dans le sac et
je suis tombé
la main dans le sac pas les pieds dans
le sac
mais bon bref alors est-ce qu'il y a du
nouveau roi des 7 bon coup alors
je comprends pas cette partie peut-être
un peu revoir un peu depuis le début là
sur cavalier
prend cavaler prend et j'ai trois on a
parlé tout à l'heure empêcher un peu les
cavaliers de venir ici
mais j'ai trois on avait pas parlé et
sur Roissy 7
et maintenant ca va les prendre H2 a été
joué et
donc on avait parlé quand même de thème
et cela peut-être que les Blancs
attendaient que le roi se pointe sur la
7ème rangée
pour pour je tour rachat un SFR qui
reprend un jeu parce que maintenant tu
reprends un chat tu reprends le chat tu
vas venir à la cachette
qui paraît logique pour un pic cavaliers
en 4
un grasse option isolé en Russie les
Noirs limite bien la majorité blanche
alors que la majorité des noirs elle a
le nom elle est très saine il se passe
rien il va il va y avoir un pion passé
tôt ou tard
mais
[Musique]
dans quoi
il dit que c'est un bon coup juste parce
que en fait c'est pas le choix ce roi B6
c'est cavalier
alors là ce qui va se passer c'est que
les Noirs veulent manger
[Musique]
7 qui va attaquer la tour défendre le
pion et prendre je crois prochain coup
et donc sur ton compte à 5 les blancs
prennent le pion mais bon ici les Noirs
mangent en G3 les pions là sont plus
fragiles quand même qu'avant tout cassé
à chaque à tout moment et au final après
un échange qui peut être perdu
c'est une possibilité
alors
tout
plus
mais qu'il est temps pas le pion le pion
ici
donc
cette partie
mais généralement quand même c'est vrai
que c'est un jour qui
veut gagner quoi
alors c'est le problème des jeunes très
forte il est un peu comme ça aussi
[Musique]
réaliste aussi avec leur chance
c'est tellement pas mon ciel tu vois
mais attends mais vous voulez gagner
tous les deux vous êtes idiot quoi
faites nul juste on en parle plus
le système des points
pousse à vouloir gagner encore plus que
d'habitude vu que
un gars une défaite c'est 3 3 points
alors que tu fais armageddouard il faut
gagner les deux arts maillots
pour avoir trois points donc
la nulle l'annuler l'appartement quoi
qui va se finir dans quelques instants
bah du coup non
je veux bien mais effectivement il y a
pas grand chose à dire
totalement
sans importance on s'est arrêté à peu
près ici avec après 4 cavaliers F5
cavaliers F3
et on a eu ces 5 de jouer par maca et la
prise
ça libère le faux mais ça change tout
donc ça pour trouver les liquidation ils
sont aussi forts que pour trouver les
répétitions de cours
[Musique]
très facile à calculer
G2 qui va les prendre
qu'on avait dit vu que surtout E5 il y a
pile le temps pour jouer à deux et
surtout Red5 pile le temps pour échanger
je vais avoir deux trois blocage très
important in extremisme très important
qui sauvent la nulle donc du coup Wesley
joue pour le gain
il va décider de faire tourner
les blancs quoi donc toujours fouder 6
il y a juste pour pour refuser les nuls
forcer quand même comme ça qu'on vient
de voir
ok
les Noirs menacent de bouger le fou
et blanc
[Musique]
préférée
à faire et avoir
même tour des cartes en fait
regardez les pièces
la première nul a été signée
pour faire plus qu'il ne réduit avec les
pièces blanches mais
il assume la qualité normalement alors
il y a eu le qu'avait les processus on
s'est arrêté à un peu ici dans cette
position et après logique
[Musique]
mais bon
tout ça
il y a eu des problèmes
[Musique]
mais bon j'ai du mal à j'ai pas Rocky en
fait c'est un truc si mon roi
c'est grave parce que là il y a même des
idées de sacrifices par exemple tomber
deux doit être un coup sur dammabilité
je sais pas si l'attaque est gagnante
mais ça fait un peu peur non
c'est compliqué
[Musique]
reposer en finale favorisent grandement
les chances de match nul mais tant que
les pièces lourdes elle a elles sont
toutes sur l'échiquier ces pièces
lourdes ça favorise les attaques vu que
chaque camp comme une pièce de plus sur
les cases de la couleur de son four donc
les Noirs jouent avec une pièce de plus
sur case blanche les blancs avec une
pièce de plus sur case noire donc
l'initiative est primordiale et donc
deux idées de sacrifice le tour comme
tourbé 2 donc clairement dans l'air ça
vous pour être certain que c'est les
joueurs calcule ça ça peut gagner en
force
bon alors après visiblement d'après la
jauge ça faisait que match nul ce qui a
priori n'est pas ce que recherche
famille mais ça on le sait pas en partie
[Musique]
c'est vraiment triste donc tu mets après
c'est pour bébé ne marche pas enfin si
ça fait que match nul
on va pas le choix
est-ce que j'aime pas c'est que ça ouvre
les cadenas par exemple
mais bon
pour rien non mais juste pour montrer
par un torrent
4 3G et maintenant
donc là les Noirs ont tous les pions de
plus du monde mais maintenant que le
blanc est en sécurité
c'est hyper chaud
la qualité ça sera pas grave parce qu'il
y a trois pions
là on va se répéter
est-ce que je peux OK
[Musique]
ben écoute
il reste 27 minutes pour jouer encore 28
coups
tu as le temps de faire un tour partout
où tu veux
tout à l'heure qu'on n'a pas regardé et
là il a toujours son petit pion de plus
Google
donc là on a eu quand même quasiment 10
coups de jouets alors
en fait il veut juste solide empêcher
d'un B2
et il veut mettre son fou sur les bonnes
cadres
j'arrive pas à faire mes diagonales mais
voilà
H5 donc on le garde il faut généralement
les meilleurs que le cavalier et des
cinq de jouets
très très logique pour
l'option c'est faible sur un cas très
fort donc
on serait très content d'échanger
mais peut-être que c'est quand même ça
le coup parce que il y a toujours
un F2 et surtout prends F2 tours un tour
Eiffel
on s'arrête là dans le calcul on se dit
par tiens est-ce que je me fais mettre
donc là il a pris en E4 donc
là on peut imaginer des principes des
quatre
fou alors est-ce que les plans seraient
contents de changer les dames je pense
que oui
mais je suis pas totalement certaine
mais bon normalement avec trois pions
devant le roi noir il sera mieux protégé
que le roi blanc à terme
ça c'est un facteur en faveur de change
de dames deuxième facteur c'est le combo
tofu qui est préférable à tourcalier
alors que dame cavalier peut être
préférable à domfrous donc je crois que
les blancs sont pas mécontents de
changer la dame si on peut jouer à un
fou les quatre et je sais pas où
échanger là mais alors après ça c'est
les considérations très général très
abstraite qui sont vraies dans la
plupart des positions est-ce que
concrètement ici il y a une occasion où
les Noirs échange de dames et force
annuler probablement
mon fruit ma tour ça peut être pas mal
mais bon est-ce que je veux faire je
suis pas sûr
mais c'est vrai qu'après parfois ça fait
de l'enfance juste tu vois
le plan C3 est faible si tu rêves 5 la
finale de tour sera nulle
ça ça c'est totalement
mais après est-ce que j'ai envie de
changer d'arme
ça touche je peux garder les pièces un
peu la pression
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder
il faut 3 tiens étrange non
très chelou
c'est un peu que j'aurais pas j'aurais
jamais joué
à la con comme
ça
[Musique]
ça serait pas de chance de pas avoir
mieux
d'accord
en plus c'est un truc un côté tonton
OK
expliquez-nous sur le classement si vous
avez une idée moi
je vois pas
[Musique]
il protège le pion cette roi il est
protégé par l'option 3 donc ouais je
vois pas d'autres explications
[Musique]
en plus c'est
très bancal comme construction
[Musique]
avec le roi là je peux pas venir
attaquer non plus et sur un truc comme
ça je peux te regarder
en fait
ça peut ça peut mettre la pression mais
c'est vrai que c'est pour ça que
toi
ça fait nul direct apparemment
les blancs joyans je suis pas très forte
mais alors les Noirs joués font nuls
er
[Musique]
coucou Fatou
alors
[Musique]
de jouer donc encore une partie qui peut
se terminer est-ce qu'il y a le niveau
pour jouer cavalier
[Rires]
il est pas en forme
évidemment qu'il le voit mais
ce qui se dit pas qu'elle G3 ça force la
nulle et est-ce que
je suis Magnus là il comprend qu'il est
plus moins bien donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'il jouerait pas pour le gars du coup
un coup autre que
quand tu reprends l'histoire de la
partie c'est toujours en fait la
position n'est jamais la même selon
l'historique de la partie on pourra se
dire que la position peu importe c'était
gagnant ou perdant avant une fois
qu'elle soit légitier
on repart d'un nouveau départ mais en
fait non c'est on est très dépendant de
l'histoire de la partie et là vu
l'histoire la Manu ça souffert il était
moins bien enfin de moins bon quête du
jeu mais voilà donc là il vient
d'égaliser donc souvent quand c'est
comme ça tu es content de faire nul mais
en vrai si tu prends le recul et que tu
dis maintenant la position elle est
égale je suis le meilleur joueur du
monde pourquoi je n'aurais pas peur
donc là c'est peut-être ce à quoi Magnus
pince alors du coup s'il faut pas jouer
quel léger 3 là je suis moins fort pour
trouver un autre bon coin
je sais pas on joue quoi sinon je veux
pas qu'elle ait trois
cavalier
je t'entends vraiment plus
qu'est-ce que tu nous as fait
[Musique]
ok bon ben je sais pas si vous
m'entendez toujours
d'admiration ouais du coup il est parti
je te vois plus non plus
alors qu'est-ce que je peux dire en plus
il nous a fait un fou franchise
sur cavalier
il y a pas d'idée
il peut y avoir du tout aussi d'ailleurs
salut
iser cette magnifique position qu'on a
à l'écran donc
les noirs
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr en fait ça marche pas
non
parce que bizarrement on peut pas
attaquer le cavalier
ça va être la dame
donc je crois que tu réussisses
réfute la combinaison de
la chance
mais d'un coup en fait il s'arrête de
marcher
c'est pas la première fois que ça me
fait ça en plus
ça marche
le fameux la fameuse technique de
brancher débrancher ouais alors sinon
entre temps j'ai refusé ton fofranchise
et les Lauriane
alors salut evan et salut Chris Blitz
pardon
alors là
on en parle plus vous peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'on en parle encore mais a
priori s'il veut jouer pour le gain il
joue pas calé de 3 c'est ça le truc
ça marche
très joli
est-ce que si vous avez dans le chat des
parties que vous voulez voir n'hésitez
surtout pas qui envoie que filou
c'est parti c'est parti en live allez
mais c'est passé ce qu'on a dit ouais
[Musique]
de résister
le premier coup qui vient l'esprit un
sacrifier la tour on avait bien expliqué
et toute couleur opposer en présence des
pièces lourdes favorise les chances
d'attaque donc l'initiative hyper cher
et donc là les Noirs prennent négatives
auprès d'une tour
mais donc ici on regardait juste pour
prendre ces deux
qui monte dès qu'on joue un coup quoi
[Musique]
[Rires]
je vais perdre ma vie là
en plus ça a l'air tellement facile
[Musique]
comment tu vas faire
j'ai 36 pions de plus donc
mais il suffit
la quantité des pions c'est la qualité
là un pion passé ça vaut cher
et j'arrive à activer mais bon ok c'est
pas simple encore
la seule idée pour
trinquer quelque chose quoi
donc dame prend des deux OK
bon ça va une partie qui va durer celle
là elle va durer et alors que tari et
saut on voit qu'ils sont en train de de
répéter je pense les arrivées
et ici est-ce qu'on peut c'est de la
gagner celle-là ou pas là
[Musique]
j'arrive à remonter
et en fait celle-ci il y a jamais de
section d'une façon
de mauvais cas
et alors tout cache-case
a commencé
on va aller voir alors
numéro 2
[Musique]
et on va vous montrer
vous allez voir les joueurs
qui ont commencé à l'instant donc la
cadence c'est 10 minutes
une petite finale de la berlinoise et en
plus
pour les blancs contre 7 pour les Noirs
c'est du chaos jusqu'au 40e coup les
joueurs les auront une seconde parcours
d'incrément chacun
donc la guirie il a du temps en plus et
il faut qu'il arrive à s'en servir pour
prendre l'avantage
la fameuse majorité
4 contre 3 à l'un endroit pour les
blancs on adorerait pouvoir jouer F4 F5
les pions h3g4 elles sont aussi sous le
jour du fouet 6 et potentiellement à
chaque peut venir
profiter de ses affaiblissements donc
là c'est quoi il a joué
et puis dominer un peu le foot
il va aussi te faire tourner à deux tout
ça peut-être aussi mais pourquoi quel
est son idée sur A5
juste F3 en fait
[Musique]
et Nakamura avec le noir a juste besoin
de faire nul
qui est intéressant aussi de voir
qu'avait G3 a été joué
que j'ai trop a été joué et on peut
imaginer l'idée de 4h5 qui peut arriver
un jour
et c'est pas facile à faire genre de
chose
quand on y arrive c'est un très bon
signe pour les blancs évidemment
ouais alors ça tourne une valeur parce
que parce que du coup les pièces noires
quand même contrôler la case des 8 un
moment donc oui il y a pas de classe de
pénétration c'est très solide mais
malinois peuvent pas faire totalement
n'importe quoi non plus
[Musique]
mais
il peut y avoir des thèmes par exemple
tu vois quand le roi est en 8 un
cavalier FC et puis tout d'un coup si tu
es chaud et puis
la case des vides devient plus plus
faible
mais là par exemple pour moi ce matin
on mangera pas on va faire quoi
maintenant
la tour est juste mieux placée en un que
n'importe quoi ailleurs quoi
c'est pas seulement pour potentiellement
prendre ou pas c'est aussi pour donner
ton Racing surtout pour 25
qui va un moment donné être sur mon
jouet il y a même aussi du Tour à 5
tours dessin je la perte de fou
B6 c'est multifonctions ça prend la
casser 5 au pièces blanches et parfois
ça prépare ses 5 et même on voit de
temps en temps la séquence ça se passe
très bien mais la meilleure diagonale
pour le coup c'est pas enfin la
meilleure place pour le fou c'est pas
aussi voilà c'est bien ça bon on en est
loin bien évidemment mais il y a des cas
où
ça arrive et quand ça arrive c'est royal
pour les noirs
ont échangé en C6 dans l'ouverture qui
leur manque maintenant et donc là j'ai
l'impression que ça se passe très bien
pour Naka qui déroule
il réfléchit pas il réfléchit pas il
joue cet homme
bon alors après c'est quand tu joues
quand tu joues au B5 contre Naka en
Armageddon tu sais que à quoi t'attendre
donc
c'est normal ça se passe pas mal non
plus pour pour Aniche c'est juste une
berlinoise comme on l'a vu des milliers
mais
pas mal n'a qu'à la perdre celle-là
alors attends j'ai alors c'est dommage
qui nous donne maintenant mais je viens
d'avoir
l'interview de Naka avant le
magasin
qui nous donne juste avant qu'on puisse
le regarder avant de avant de voir un
magasin mais là j'ai envie de te dire je
regarderai pas
donc
c'est pas encore joué en fait sur F4 il
y a souvent des moyens cassés un peu
tout rapidement et ouvrir en fait la
position pour les fous aussi sur le roi
donc c'est pas évident à jouer et à tous
les deux c'est vraiment très bien aussi
parce que on voit bien que les Noirs
enfin les Noirs ils mettent des pions
sur 15 mois pour jouer contre le foot
case noir pour après avoir le mode qui
va rayonner sur le cache blanche quoi
donc c'est
et d'ailleurs j'ai envie de dire que
avant que je fous B7 il va sûrement
faire faux assise d'abord pour provoquer
peut-être ces quatre et à ce moment-là
peut-être faire C5 et trouver 7 les
pions sont fixés
pour voir jouer la berlinoise juste à me
mettre à 4,5 à mon âge ça fait un
travail
si j'avais la garantie que mon
adversaire allait échanger à la
berlinoise qu'est-ce que l'horreur avoir
final de la baleine noire pour le reste
de mes jours je pense que je serai genre
améliorer l'eau mais
malheureusement quatre cinq je me prends
n'importe quel Gambie à la con
et je perds
mais bon
la position
et le roi qui va généralement là je
pense cette partie
pour protéger les pions et ensuite
préparer
F40
n'est pas en prise parce que faut les
quatre trous la tour
[Musique]
on a
assez envie de faire F4
aussi alors là peut-être tout de suite
non
casser un peu la structure pour réussir
à manger là plus tard mais là
fou peut-il vraiment lâcher contre la
case de Sète
évidemment ça dépend des positions
le flux il reste là il attend mais
pendant que le fouet là
donc en fait bon
à rien parce que vous pouvez aussi ça
j'ai cette menace probablement j'ai 5
maintenant
la prise durable
G5
donc après c'est 5 Le Fou est prêt à
venir en fait
même se retrouver
pas assez confort
[Musique]
mais ouais donc enfin voilà la colonne A
est ouverte pour la barre à l'esprit toi
de peut arriver tôt ou tard
renforce un peu là je contrôle aussi
c'est une idée parce que c'était débile
c'est simple
est-ce que ça vaut vraiment la peine de
venir prendre la colonne
pour je suis en couple passif et après
ben juste ok mon profil
[Musique]
c'est très dangereux pour les blancs
parce que
[Musique]
est-ce que tu arrives jamais à faire F5
blanche pour
tfourage
vraiment je pense que je leur ai joué à
chaque jour
j'étais pas trop sur H5 je pense que je
l'aurais pas joué à 5 enfin
[Musique]
après parfois je vais peut-être
probablement que je joue parfois quand
c'est mauvais c'est toujours pareil mais
c'est clairement dans ma reine je crois
est-ce que
un des gros problèmes c'est que à chaque
fois il faut prendre S6 et
il faut que le reposer et bon courage au
pion prend il faut être fuite
[Musique]
changer un peu des tours
on arrive en fonction on se fait mater
sur case noire
ça peut arriver ça sera un peu ballot
mais il y a du mal potentiel donc là par
exemple
une minute 40 contre 2 minutes ils sont
38e couple 2000 enfin du coup pardon de
quoi avant d'arriver au 40e coup le pion
B4 est très faible et c'est important
parce que sinon
garder le faux de casse blanche entre un
cavalier potentiellement fort mais
c'est pas
par ici
c'est faible mais le pion B4 il est
encore plus
c'est la partie
[Musique]
mate de partout
il y a une seconde parcours et là ça y
est
en fait j'ai trois colonnes à garder
j'ai deux tours
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour sortir
échec et chacun
[Musique]
tu prends et tu fais ça attention mais
tu manges le tu manges
il y avait 5 était marrants
et abandons donc nakaki
alors on aura 20h15 la partie entre
enfin l'Armageddon entre Paris et slows
qui ont bien fait nul
on
en a ici j'ai une autre scène pour 45
[Musique]
la vue du dessus
mais elle est bien pour le pour le
départage mais peut-être là on peut voir
il reste pas beaucoup de temps
c'est laquelle déjà je crois que c'est
là
bon là juste un petit point à noter que
les pions G2 et j'ai trois doubles
isolés sont souvent faibles évidemment
mais en finale il y a une grande force
c'est à dire une bonne question facile
majorité FGH comment placer deux pions
blancs pour que les Noirs ne puisse pas
se sacrifier
ne puisse pas se créer un pion passé
sans sacrifier un pion une patient j'ai
deux trois tu en a des pions genre F2 et
G2 les Noirs vont pouvoir se créer un
pion passé en poussant le pion h d'abord
etc face à des pions doublés isolés au
milieu j'ai 2 G3 impossible de créer un
plan passé
bon avec des pions doublés à la A2 et à
droite sur évidemment c'est aussi
impossible une pâte assez pas de temps
passé pas de dames pas de dames
donc c'est totalement nul alors après
peut-être que ma news peut jouer quand
même il y a un plan
mais c'est de juste ramener le roi
ramener le roi direction un tour du
monde et on veut gagner les deux pions
aucun moyen de d'arnaquer ça avec
avec les Noirs je pense que ça va faire
une nulle alors on lui demande de faire
un bilan sur le chat des résultats donc
on peut vous les mettre ici pour
l'instant il y a eu que deux parties de
terminer donc c'est des poules non c'est
un taux de ronde
on les appelle avec une grande
spécificité la victoire vaut trois
points la défaite 0 et en cas de match
nul tu gagnes un point d'office plus tu
joues un armaidon pour 0,5 points donc
là vous voyez les résultats à neige
guéri 1 parce qu'il a fait match nul et
perdu la remarié d'eau et qu'un
ronakamura 1,5 parce qu'il a fait ma
chenule en partie classique puis gagner
l'armée
[Musique]
viennent de faire match nul je rentre
donc l'Armageddon pour le demi-point
supplémentaire et sinon quelle victoire
c'est trois points pour l'instant en
tête de tournoi carwana qui a fait
victoire en partie classique plus un
match nul en partie classique et
victoire à l'armée dedans et là en plus
il est bien il est très bien face à
firoga donc s'il fait une troisième
victoire en partie classique déjà comme
d'habitude
un + 3 c'est excellent plus trois sur un
tournoi 9 ronde ça fait souvent gagner
le tournoi de manière générale à ce
niveau là de jeu c'est tellement rare de
faire par trois gains et c'est nuls
mais dans un tournoi avec avec ce
système c'est peut-être encore plus quoi
mais voilà car on a peu s'envoler sur la
tête et Caro est pas mal mais il a fait
il a fait quoi le Caro oui il a battu et
il a gagné une partie
sur 12
alors qu'il va perdre une partie mais
juste il en a gagné deux donc voilà un
deux victoires 6 points
ça fait 6 sur 12 au final ce qui est
marrant avec ce système c'est que tu
peux gagner le tournoi en perdant la
moitié des parties quoi
[Musique]
alors on va revenir sur notre scène
c'est pas mal cette semaine
donc alors
on en est là F6 soit on disait qu'on
n'arrivait pas à voir normalement c'est
totalement nul
pas trop idée
F6 Magnus peut-être laisse les blancs
jouer un coup échec donc le fait n'est
pas emprise attention
il faut se méfier est-ce que c'est
toujours un vrai moins faut faire
[Musique]
ouais alors après ça semble quand même
mieux
en dessin et puis que tu vas faire quoi
mais en fait tout nul quoi
est-ce qu'il y a des vraies idées
je pense pas
la dame elle a plus rien attaquer
non mais tu vois
tu vois je peux le faire moi aussi
apprendre et maintenant c'est moi qui
joue pour la dame
non c'est juste
c'est juste nul mais
on dirait du Johnny Hallyday
ouais bon bah du coup autre partie
peut-être plus intéressante magicien des
final qu'il est là il y aura du mal
alors Pierrot il se passe quoi là
[Musique]
merci de nous le faire remarquer je me
suis trompé de scène voilà on est bien
dans la scène merci à toi
j'avais une question est-ce qu'on joue
plutôt avec ces cinq ou B5 qui a l'air
pas mal
ouais
du coup on a pas mal
ouais mais en fait ça va dépendre de ce
qu'on fait les blancs parce que bon je
vais essayer ici
damelin
er
parce que
tu es pas bien
et si je fais il faut pas oublier qu'on
a une tour de moi quoi donc
très chaud
[Musique]
et puis il faut pas oublier que les
joueurs n'ont pas la jauge donc
après intuitivement on sent depuis le
début tomber dans l'avait proposé parce
que c'est tellement le coup t'entend et
on sait que faut que le reposer tout ça
les choses d'attaque sont décuplés
donc ça sent que ça va très bien pour
aller noir en fait si tu sais pas
l'évaluation il y a un monde où tu te
dis mais en fait j'ai pas mieux tu vois
tu commences à paniquer à barceleurs de
variante ou hasard tu te prends
aussi soin de variante et
le 2 et puis
après je vois pas je vois pas Fabi du
tout paniquer prendre la mais en fait si
peut-être qu'il se dit que c'est que
c'est pas clair du tout
[Musique]
mais
apparemment ça tient pas sur la même
idée tu manges aussi
F5
[Musique]
quand tu veux de toute façon donc
tu peux te dire que la position est pas
encore
enfin je sais pas à quel point tu es
certain que c'est gagnant et ça sent que
c'est gagnant mais le point en incertain
alors il a joué H4 on imagine
et maintenant fou B5 peut-être
donc il faut que je défende autrement
j'ai pas le choix
et maintenant là faut calculer
assez fort mais il faut terminer il faut
punir
du coup tu vois H4
j'ai pas le choix
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est de la part pas
c'est qu'il aura il aura bien défendu et
que et qu'il aura bien défendu et que
Fabien se sera trompé quoi
oui mais ça
c'est ma femme
ah c'est juste
je voyais le matin
[Musique]
non non je sais ce que c'est ah non non
ok bon c'est chaud six contre 3 le rat
blanc était hyper sèche tant qu'il y
avait le fou du champ cadeau mais
maintenant
mais par exemple là pour 5 mais par
exemple juste pour ici ça menace pour
reprendre tu reprends un cadre sans que
tu prends
ici
apparemment c'est un mauvais coup
pourquoi non mais juste une vieille
[Rires]
alors attends qu'est-ce qui se passe là
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
ces trois la tour elle est enfermée en
fait dans ma tête c'est le coup de génie
qui permet de prendre toutes les cases
de la tour
et qui menace
qu'il faut y penser c'est tellement le
pire couple
c'est difficile d'y penser alors que ça
gagne une tordre un coup en fait
c'est incroyable
tous vos quatre étaient joués
il y a eu zéro chance
[Musique]
il y a peu de joueurs qui emblés en sasa
en fait si tu sais que c'est un gain tu
vas le trouver assez rapidement
il y a pas 36000 idées mais quand tu
sais pas qu'il y a un gars il te remplit
les noirs sont mieux
Laura blanc est plus fort que le roi
Loire simplement
[Musique]
je suis
mais il a un peu de temps la pendule
quand même
on va la voir la finale
[Musique]
les gens aiment bien
après la partie si ça vous va
peut-être prise pour des deux et de
passer le roi
mais bon je dois pas avoir grand-chose
ici
par exemple
à 5 et courir vite
il faut partir vite
c'est une course salut François A5 cours
forest
alors
attention
à cette suite en haut et tout racisme
objectif
mais quand même suffisamment
pour être pour être fatigué mais ça va
c'est que la Taure noire se sacrifie à
la fin mais bon
[Musique]
même moi je peux pas le poids c'est là
il y a pas il y a pas d'arnaque
parce que j'ai envie d'aller plus vite
mais bon
j'ai trois va aussi en fait mais prise
tac secouer
en fait
donc en fait très très large donc
bien sûr
aucun intérêt on veut se faire violer
en tout cas
mais il prend des risques quand même
donc la droite quand même pour laisser
le passé
sur on sait jamais surprise peuvent
arriver
et là tu peux pousser je prends qui fait
dames je fais dame dame pion creux d'âme
tu verras jamais
là il faut manger je pense ça m'a prise
je prends du piano tu pousses je fais
dames tu fais dames et c'est juste nul
en fait c'est même mieux ce qu'il a fait
parce que
il a un pion qui avance comme ça
par rapport
c'est comme ça que tu termines comme ça
un minimum
ça c'est la ça c'est une finale
théorique vous savez d'un pion contre
enfin d'armes contre wrapions c'est
gagnant si les pions est pas sur la 7ème
rangée ou la deuxième avec les couleurs
inversées et aussi plusieurs cases où ça
fait nul si le point est un cas de la
dame on a cette case là celle-là
celle-là et celle là pourquoi c'est nul
parce qu'en fait après chaque enfin
apprendre pardon après par exemple échec
je monte essayer d'aller
la grosse nuance là c'est que l'on peut
faire croire à 8 qui continue à menacer
Damas
recommencerait la même manœuvre
rapprochera le roi etc
[Musique]
central un autre pion
de pâtes avec un peu de tour il y a une
autre histoire de pâte c'est que quand
l'orage met devant le pion
avec un pion à 7 on peut on peut pas
j'ai le droit parce que c'est parti
on va aller voir sa partie
alors et la partie ah pardon
c'est chaud
il a pris ici
j'ai regardé
4 pions pour la qualité et j'ai trois
peuple
mais
c'est pas une partie de plaisir là pour
pour fioulx
parce que avec le roi noir des petites
choses d'attaque de perpétuer afin
d'attaque pas de maths on s'entend bien
mais
reste faible longue techniquement faut
toujours faire un petit peu attention
mais bon là au moins il y a plus aucun
doute sur l'évaluation
totalement gagnants après évidemment
qui remonte voilà attends
[Musique]
bonne soirée bonne soirée à toi et
rentre bien
[Musique]
toujours un petit espoir sur le rat noir
en Espagne quoi mais bon
je crois que
je sais que c'est un espoir 20 mais bon
[Musique]
je pense que vous allez voir dans mes
fuites c'est sûr que c'est le coup qui
va être joué et je pense que vous allez
les voir peut-être
[Musique]
sur le champ après dans la fuite ecoute
grosse partie de sa vie sa vie qui fait
qui fait un grand folie
en classique dans ce tournoi il va être
dur à aller chercher
mes familles étaient loin de son top il
était même redescendu en dessous de 50
ou même en dessous là
il avait perdu beaucoup de points ces
derniers temps quoi
quatre mondiales au pire tu vois
il est passé peut-être je sais plus
peut-être 3 ou 4 ans plus au dessus de
1800 €
[Musique]
à mondial juste Magnus était trop fort
quoi
[Musique]
il aurait dû être numéro à mondial c'est
juste il y avait pas
le monstre Magnus quoi ouais en fait
chacun tu es souvent dans la la mauvaise
génération
alors c'est pas grave
S
[Musique]
je l'ai pas mais
bon
[Musique]
la vidéo oui c'est normal en fait quand
je tous les trucs
[Musique]
à quel point je serai confiante de faire
nul contre Magnus Carson cette position
non moi je ferai toujours
mais non je sais pas tu mets la cote à
combien quoi
pour toi
non pour toi
tu sais qu'en final je te fais plus
confiance
non en fait je serai horrible
je serai je crois je serai hyper
confiant avec je la perds à la fin en
fait puis faire confiance de faire nul
et à la fin je me prends une peau de
banane
et tu vas et tu vas perdre quoi
en plus tu vois c'est un contre Magnus
ou tu sais que il va toujours trouver
toutes les idées mais là on en voit
tellement pas
non mais en fait le problème c'est que
Magnus alors on l'a expliqué là il y a
un campus pour les pour les Noirs ici un
jeu de plus en plus pour les blancs mais
en fait enfin je passe jamais et ce côté
là il y a un peu plus mais dès que tu
vas pousser des pions on va se découvrir
quand même donc un moment donné il y
aura plus de chance de gains si le
purgeait 3 et 3 par exemple
alors évidemment passer cette louée mais
sinon
on l'échange
d'ailleurs comment je joue là pour
empêcher
pas peur
j'ai 4
attention que ça peut être joli
et en fait sur ça ça il y a peut-être ça
mais la tête que je mange maintenant et
je prends là
éloigné et de plus
[Musique]
G4 parce que
c'était pas un coup
je reviens à la maison
ok
j'ai pas d'idée c'est ça qui me dit
[Musique]
que je peux en fait
ça fait nul et
Armageddon à 55
[Musique]
si je devais passer ou si je pouvais
plutôt si je pouvais passer une soirée
avec
les joueurs enfin un des joueurs du
tournoi en tête-à-tête je choisirais
quand on
avait passé une douce soirée avec
d'autres personnes
je crois que la connaissance
[Musique]
[Rires]
je peux pas
ça y est je crois que le chat on l'a
réveillé là mais moi on m'avait dit un
truc ça m'a un peu surpris mais ok
on en reparlera
d'abord
Paris
je le mets 3 euros
[Rires]
et après il m'a dit dans la tête trop
forte
[Rires]
avec tous ces gens-là parce que en vrai
c'est marrant quoi
un côté
ok c'était quand même avec les joueurs
[Musique]
il faisait vraiment dans son monde
c'est-à-dire et je sais pas un début de
soirée on était dans un bar et regarder
un match de foot
tout en pensée de veille qui pensait aux
échecs enfin c'est plus dans son monde
et
Kawana si tu sais pas s'il était 2800
c'était le mec
très sympa un peu peut-être un peu
timide mais très cool et puis
à l'écoute enfin toi tu pouvais parler
il s'intéresse à toi et poser des
questions enfin c'est vraiment super
super humain
super être humain
tu sais que j'étais allé à Dresde en
2007 je crois
2008 il me semble 2008
oui et
j'avais un ticket pour rentrer dans le
bah il y a il y avait la fameuse soirée
dans l'UDA
et j'y étais allé en fait et en fait
c'était un truc bizarre
en fait je sais pas c'était vraiment ça
mais il y avait une soirée il y avait
une soirée et dans une discothèque voilà
de là-bas j'ai vu tout le monde
en fait standard et tout et puis j'ai
parlé à cartel et puis et puis donc
c'était avec un pote à moi qui était
suédois en fait moi j'étais allé en tant
que ça on avait un sort de yacht camp
organisé et j'y étais et du coup j'étais
là semaine on fait un échec et puis le
soir on allait voir les Olympiades et
après j'avais eu le truc de la de la
comment dire parmi la partie mais je
pouvais pas y aller parce que je t'ai
mineur à l'époque et mais bon j'avais
quelqu'un qui connaissait quelqu'un
voilà et en fait j'étais rentré et mais
je suis pas resté tard
non c'est vrai en plus c'est vrai toi tu
m'as connu mais ça c'était plus tard
c'était plus tard attention
mais oui mais en fait quand j'ai pas la
Carlson il avait l'air d'être s'en
royalement dans le sens politique
c'est pas forcément le mec le plus le
plus sympa
quand il te répond en fait il regarde à
côté quoi genre enfin bon pas tout à
l'heure
dans son monde
ça doit il y a un côté chiant aussi
parce que c'est vraiment une super star
tu vois contrairement à carbonara
n'est pas du tout là c'est quand car on
a donc Magnus on m'a raconté plein
d'histoires ou soit il se fait un peu
harceler enfin c'est ok c'est pas ma
donna mais tu vois c'est que ce soit
dans la rue évidemment chaque chaque
soirée je dois rajoute aux échecs tout
le monde veut lui parler et puis un
moment je pense que
tu en peux plus aussi mais donc pas
remplie de soirée qui fait en Norvège là
ça a l'air sympa quand même tu vois
quand il est avec ses potes ils ont
l'air de bien s'amuser quand même mais
bon
une star c'est c'est
tout de suite pas facile en fait on se
met pas forcément à la place des gens
aussi dans la rue dans la rue chez lui
tout le monde le reconnaît tout le monde
tout le monde veut la bordel quoi donc
n'importe alors en attendant ça c'est la
partie c'est la position de la partie
non
bof tu penses en fait il y a des raisons
5 échec c'est une menace non depuis tout
à l'heure c'est la même chose
à moins que tu me fasses ça ça
dans ce cas là peut-être que je peux lui
faire G3
parce que bien sûr la finale alors là
c'est au bout de ce genre de jeu
la finale bien sûr échec je mange pas
hein si je mange j'ai un peu Basset etc
sur chaque peut-être j'ai trois juste et
là tu vas être obligé de manger je
prendrai de l'argent
[Musique]
j'ai trois il y a plein de cas aussi où
vous supprimez perdu sur un chèque tu
vois mais
non j'ai trois des blancs
si la dame était ailleurs le pion est
perdu mais pas seulement perdu il est
perdu sur les chats donc c'est la
catastrophe elle trouve qu'elle a
m'embête 5 couvre les cas importantes
enfin la case importante pour la fin
mais
là je serai plus du tout sur elle en
fait je commencerai à me dire mais
attends mais je suis en train je suis en
train vraiment de la perdre quoi
c'est un peu arnaqué
donc ouais ben écoute
[Musique]
dans B3
mais du coup je commence à pousser
pionner aussi
un gagnable qui gagne tu as même quand
on est au courant on est toujours
surprise tu vois c'est
vraiment c'est le magicien tu fais un
tour de magie une fois ok tu as compris
et puis là tu refais le mettre tout
reste encore et tu vois c'est
extraordinaire
et tout d'un coup ce qui pensait
totalement un peu cible il y a vraiment
pas si longtemps ben devient devient de
l'heure du plausible et puis en plus tu
connais l'histoire tu as la pression
psychologique tu as la pression de la
pendule elle est en plus il joue très
bien parce que il a attendu un peu avant
de de procéder à l'échange de pion
achète du pion G3 donc l'adversaire
commence à douter comment savoir peu de
temps et puis faut se rappeler que c'est
du gros diagnostes
n'est plus obligé de noter ses coups
pourquoi parce qu'il a moins de 5
minutes
quand on en rajoutant 30 secondes on est
obligé de noter ce coup pour tout le
reste de la partie mais quand le rajout
de temps est inférieur à 30 secondes et
ici il n'est que de 10 secondes
dès que tu as moins de 5 minutes tu es
plus obligé de noter et si vous va
d'ailleurs si vous vous posez la
question qu'est-ce qui se passe et tu
remontes au dessus de 5 minutes ben tu
peux quand même obligé de noter
évidemment tu n'as pas reprendre à
chaque fois que tu repasses au dessus
donc on a une autre plus c'est cool là
il a l'impression de jouer un blitz en
fait
est-ce que cette scène elle vous va
mieux avec le jack note de gouquet vous
préférez cette scène là moi je préfère
dites moi dans le chat
ce que vous préférez
avec avec le plan mansbal
[Musique]
plan sur le chignon de Magnus
avec le chouchou
ouais c'est cool en fait
allez on laisse comme ça les gens
adorent depuis qu'ils nous voient plus
je sais pas comment il faut le prendre
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un côté Julien
Doré
la pression du temps et tout
et continuer à le noter
tu es fou
oui mais lui là
on avait déjà eu cette discussion avec
je crois que c'était Antoine que j'avais
fait et non ben c'est
une autre
normalement la règle je crois
mais les joueurs notés à chaque fois
donc je sais pas
non mais peut-être pas habitué alors en
fait tu as quand même un intérêt à noter
c'est pour réclamer la nul
trois fois la même position
mais là en plus vu que c'est retransmis
en direct je pense que tu peux quand
même réclamer la nul
même si tu notes plus mais je suis pas
totalement certaine parce qu'en fait en
théorie pour être la mélanine c'est très
codifié ça tu dois écrire le ton
prochain coup
arrêter la pendule
oui ça c'est les cadeaux je vais jouer
ce coup ça va faire trois fois
l'imposition ou ça va faire 50 coups que
il y a pas eu de capture et de
possession la vie de vérifier sur ta
feuille de partie et ben voilà de faire
nulle ou pas et donc quand tu auras de
noter comment est-ce que tu fais alors
pour répondre à ton plier au milieu de
noter mais
l'incrément doit de 30 secondes pour
changer mais moi je me rappelle même
Dieu du top jeune je sais pas tu as
connu ça au top jeune ou c'est j'en ai
joué il y a très longtemps ça s'appelait
même national une jeune à l'époque
et dans les parties des grands c'était
en plus 30 secondes je crois mais les
parties des petits c'était 50 + 10 - 50
+ 10 donc on disait bien dès que tu as
moins de 5 minutes
[Musique]
donc après ça peut changer mais en même
temps ça paraît normal tu imagines
l'incrément il est 2 secondes
non mais oui c'est clair mais
c'est pas ça me paraît bizarre mais
maintenant que c'est c'est une partie
qui est
entremet supervisée il y a un arbitre il
y a les caméras
contour contre Sacha costelio et juste
il a défendu pendant 150 coups
elle joue tu vois mais ça fait 200
couilles un peu plus puis là il fait
l'erreur et puis elle le punit
en fait il avait juste à demander la nul
quoi
il pensait qu'il avait pas le droit
rapide de réclamer la nul mais
après les règles les règles et les
cadences et tout change tout le temps il
y a une discussion passionnante sur que
sont les boissons
ma façon c'est un sponsor du tournoi
donc ça on pourrait savoir
le débat Naka qui boit du Red Bull il
avait un sponsor red bulle mais j'avais
entendu dire que dans il est pas
forcément du Red Bull dans son Red Bull
bref je sais pas si non mais il peut
mettre ce qu'il veut dans leur red bulle
mais après ils sont sponsor mais si
j'aime pas ça et
on m'a enfin j'avais entendu dire que il
veut pas forcément du Red Bull même si
il a fait la canette Red Bull
je comprends avec t'es pas forcément
envie non j'ai déjà fait en partie des
chèques quand on est très fatigué
parfois ça arrive un petit coup de Red
Bull mais d'ailleurs il faut faire gaffe
Red Bull c'est quand même bien café
henné et contre l'antidopage la caféine
à haute dose mais genre c'est en plus
que ça genre huit café
[Musique]
un homme de 75 kg va être positif
oui il y a des contrôles antidopage aux
échecs
c'est bizarre mais c'est comme ça
il y a très peu de dopage dans les
achats enfin moi je suis au courant de
rien
peut-être aux États-Unis j'imagine parce
que aux Etats-Unis c'est il y a toute la
culture des
étudiants sont dopés en fait enfin tous
bien plus qu'en France quoi il y a
énormément de médicaments qui a de la
concentration et les étudiants
américains sont shootées à ça quoi donc
peut-être qu'aux États-Unis ça contamine
le jeu de chaque mais en France je
connais personne qui qui prend quoi que
ce soit alors que
alors que il y a sûrement quelques
molécules qui pourraient aider mais je
ne sais pas
question alors je te laisse choisir
est-ce que tu veux rester sur ça ou
est-ce que tu vois des voir le départage
Armageddon entre
je te propose qu'on demande au chat et
ensuite on décide indépendamment de leur
réponse mais on demande au chat d'abord
allez on va demander à Yuma de nous
faire une une sorte de de
[Musique]
la question c'est est-ce qu'on regarde
la fin de la partie classique de Magnus
ou est-ce qu'on regarde l'armée dedans
ouais
[Rires]
à côté de
Google après si vous voulez peut-être
pas bête
vous voulez que je mette un échec à côté
de Google
qui m'embête un peu parce que moi aussi
du coup il va falloir finir par
respecter la vie du public
j'ai pas cette scène sur les autres
parties mais c'est vrai qu'à les voir
l'Armageddon quand même c'est sympa
aussi
en termes de cadence c'est tout aussi
rapide le Magnus il a que 5 minutes
aussi c'est que plus 10 secondes la
roquette dans l'autre c'est du chaos
mais enfin plus ou moins 10 secondes ça
va vite quoi
après on peut on peut switcher
elle a commencé la partie
c'est une
[Musique]
ouais une sorte de
je crois
merci
c'est toi le chef c'est toi le chef
j'aurais insisté pour qu'on reste sur ma
news mais parce que le public a voté à
Magnus je veux bien
[Musique]
puis ensuite rapidement sur Magnus
là c'est une finale il se passe pas
grand chose les banques qui attendent
et puis un peu en tout cas après on se
fiche sur ma news
on va regarder un peu tout ce qui se
passe à faire le sondage
[Rires]
j'adore ce concept
le vote de public à ne pas le respecter
c'est la base il m'a dit
[Rires]
merci publique
[Musique]
tu peux pas me battre sur sur twitch
Robinson
après si connecte avec casse comme fr là
j'ai broyé de me faire Banner mais avec
son compte à lui il peut il peut pas me
est-ce que je peux voir ce qu'il avait
super bien
mais après je peux me connecter avec un
autre compte c'est le compte froid
[Musique]
j'aime bien mais
un coup un koala
toute sa vie
il a nourri sa famille en juin F4 LG 4
donc là il peut faire les deux
mais c'est quand même
ne pas respecter c'est un peu mon cadre
respect au fouet
plus jamais jouer F3 donc si jamais il y
a une batterie il faut baisser cette
dame de 5 on peut arriver il va falloir
gérer les menaces autrement
donc bon là visiblement l'idée c'est de
jouer ma peau celle-ci
c'était contre danse pas comme Google
il a tout envoyé dans la gueule la ronde
1 Armageddon et à la fin il a dit de
toute façon moi l'Armageddon j'ai
compris j'ai les blancs j'en vois tout
j'envoie tout parce que Ben la nul je
perds donc il faut vraiment que je mate
quoi donc H4 G4 de partout il a fait la
même contre gouquettes contre Paris et
en fait il disait que leur magasin la
bonne stratégie c'est de faire ça et le
tout pour le match et
ben là c'est un peu ce qu'il fait parce
que F4
niveau amateur bon déjà enfin il y a
rarement
de tournois qui le propose mais en fait
au niveau amateur c'est les blancs en
énorme avantage parce qu'en fait il y a
quasiment jamais de ne l'emblème regarde
sur internet il y a tellement d'erreurs
qu'il y a très peu de nuls le
pourcentage de nuls au top niveau sur
Internet c'est très élevé évidemment
mais on y va matin quand tu regardes les
parties
tu vois
mais du coup si on parle du principe que
la partie va jamais se terminer par la
nullement mais normalement tu as acheté
des plantes avantages de la pendule donc
[Musique]
je la regarde en même temps t'inquiète
pas robinside j'ai je vois les deux
parties moi
mais je peux pas vous la montrer désolé
après on peut
l'air pas
mal le cavalier
6 lui il est à l'hôtel lequel
on peut se cavaluer cet échec donc tu es
sur une mauvaise casse tu peux pas
bouger voilà là il menace juste de
doubler
un petit peu
[Musique]
on a quand même pas mal
Raptor x salut à toi bienvenue
donc là on aime beaucoup les blancs
après laquelle noire commence des
patouilles adorent C8
ok donc il envoie 5 et le contre le jeu
j'ai envie de dire
du contre-jour sur le bras blanc parce
que c'est clair s'il a si ça reste
tranquille tu ressors même
un moment
tellement mieux à la dame
c'était ce que je disais jusqu'à ce que
je me rends compte que torse 8 sera
toujours cavaluation
et ben je vais manger là-haut
et au final je gagne une qualité et si
je mange de la tour et ben je mange la
tour qui derrière là
donc en fait attention ça me lasse rien
et toi c'est le Dame des 6
j'aime vraiment bien ça rappelle aux
blancs qu'ils ont joué quand même le
pion F le pion h le noir blanc et
durablement
pas à l'instant ça va mais il y aura
toujours du jeu sur le bras blanc
osé de l'autre côté le cavalier noir ben
il Langeais 6 fois ah oui oui non non en
fait je pense c'est un très bon coup
[Musique]
salut mon gré
une fois la qualité perdue 5
le 3
alors
je sais pas mais dans tous les cas tu as
pas envie de jouer comme ça tu t'arrêtes
là
ça va alors
peut-être que mais bon en pratique tu
calcules pas
où c'est foutu en plus de le faire je
peux le faire sur un autre moment une
meilleure manière
c'est très naturel de vouloir doubler
mais c'est pour ça qu'il a joué comme
des 6 d'abord comme ça il y a plus de
cavaliers
[Musique]
j'ai pas mis les caméras parce que bon
j'entre deux hein
[Musique]
ça va répéter là ça va dans un instant
vous aurez les
en fait Google
[Musique]
mais ça va pas
partout en fait si la dame quitte la
case 1 tes maths
[Musique]
à la place de bocage donc c'est normal
qu'on dirait que tu as 40 ans
il y a une semaine mais maintenant il a
17 ans en plus on dirait qu'il a 42 ans
de faire plus que son âge donc c'est pas
si
je suis un peu les deux des deux côtés
[Musique]
[Rires]
sur Internet c'est beaucoup en live
c'est très très peu ça passe tellement
vite
attention il y a plein de tactiques
de voir la médié là ça m'a rappelé mon
premier souvenir avec lui c'était après
un top 5 justement où
il glisser contre tout le monde alors 5
minutes une minute évidemment lui avec
mais tous les grands maîtres à 2500
français y passaient et les exposait
tous quoi
je crois que c'était Laurent du monde
junior il faisait la même chose il
jouait 5 minutes
ils font 50% de poids moyenne évidemment
mais du coup on oublie à quel point ils
sont ils sont monstrueux quoi
tellement difficile d'être grand maître
il y a tellement une classe même
plusieurs classes d'écart entre un grand
maître lambda entre guillemets et ces
gens là
c'est fou
il y a tellement de trucs
la jauge elle bouge pas mais ça me
paraît pas du tout évident
je pense que ça va être abandon bientôt
il abandonné allez on va sur quinzen
en plus avec 20 secondes
il faut pas se prendre un mp3 échec qui
serait pas heureux
direct
j'ai deux
échecs alors on est chacun à une case de
la dame je pense que ça va faire nul non
j'aurais chèque pour sécuriser
[Musique]
il peut y avoir des thèmes de géant
d'âme d'un projet etc un moment
si l'autre
attention il y a plus de temps là
à plus de temps
[Musique]
ça paraissait vraiment à perdable et
puis un moment ça c'est vraiment perdant
il essaye et ce qui complètement ouf en
fait c'est c'est la capacité de Carlson
à juste trouver des complications dans
une position qui avait l'air
complètement morte
pour faire nul bon après avoir vu ça non
non c'est clair que je la perte tous les
jours en fait même avec une oeuvre à la
pendule juste là ou cache à dû trouver
des coups à un moment moi ça a jamais
été totalement sur le film mais
clairement un moment ça puait grave et
il a fallu bien joué
[Musique]
il commence très souvent mal cet endroit
et il est fini très souvent bien enfin
mal pour ces standards mais Magnus qui
vient de partir en quatre ans c'est pas
tous les jours non plus
de temps
on va avoir
l'Armageddon entre ces deux joueurs donc
l'Armageddon en plus on aura droit à
cette belle scène
pour pour les suivre
je te propose iosha qu'on se base
de 5 minutes le temps qu'on reçoit un
petit peu dans les instructions de camp
va être l'Armageddon qu'on se pose un
petit peu avant
le final voilà
[Musique]
mais c'est pour ça c'est Fatou ok bon
enfin tout est en Norvège les gars
donc voilà on se fait une petite pause
si vous voulez de de 5 minutes et on
revient on revient dans un instant
de retour non
et avec le dénouement de cette belle
journée à tout de suite à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/avent scoop tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent aussi
bien sur le site internet que sur nos
applications iOS et Android pour vivre
votre passion comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour pour
l'Armageddon entre Magnus Carlson et
goket
dernière partie de la journée
dernière partie que c'est terminé donc
par match nul après que Manuel Carson a
tout essayé
dans cette finale de dames mais gokash a
bien défendu
s'annule et là maintenant vous cache va
devoir faire mieux que match nul face à
ce qu'on demande il va devoir le battre
enfin face au champ du monde au champion
du monde de blés
c'est vrai que je suis pas encore
habitué à parler de ma news comme plus
le champion du monde maintenant
il va devoir le battre parce que c'est
la manière dont il commence à partir de
10 minutes et le Magnin seulement 7 mais
en cas de match nul mainus cartel
obtient un demi point supplémentaire je
rappelle le système de points trois
points pour une victoire en plastique 0
pour une défaite en classique un point
de garantie en cas de match nul en
classique et un demi point de bonus pour
une victoire en Armageddon
donc c'est tout l'enjeu de cette partie
se précieux de mes points même si quand
on regarde les scores de Caravana
évidemment il s'est bien envolé là
carvana sale leader de loin de ce
tournoi mais bon il peut mettre
l'accélérateur assez vite et finir
en roue libre
j'ai une surprise pour toi
j'ai une surprise pour toi mais par
contre
surprends-moi s'il te plaît
[Musique]
sur la difficulté à obtenir des
positions gagnantes
avec les deux couleurs
que donc il a dit
à part si tu joues toutes les ouvertures
et que tu te sens bien dans toutes les
ouvertures aura ce genre de position
hyper plate
donc effectivement il y a quand même des
petites chances et que Ariana ensuite
bien défendu il espérait avoir la partie
jouer pour le gain quand même
pas très en forme dans ce tournoi
et ensuite dans l'armagadon alors
effectivement il y a eu la confirmation
que cette roi n'a pas du tout donc il y
avait un fameux enfermement de Tours là
qu'on avait montré mais c'était vraiment
très bien caché
tu peux le remonter avant la partie de
mainus juste avant si tu veux
raté et ben là c'est le journaliste qui
l'a qui l'a appris à Wesley avait pas du
tout pensé ni pendant ni après la partie
évidemment
c'était ici
il y a eu dans la tête et H6 mauvais
coup parce que C3 et ben la tour n'a
plus de pièces n'a plus de 15 c'est ouf
mais donc voilà il a dit que il avait
aussi parlé de la difficulté qu'on les
joueurs à switché à l'Armageddon c'est
vrai que quand tu as le rythme de la
partie classique et même quand ça se
finit dans Death Note c'est pas du tout
la même chose
donc certains joueurs dans le tournoi et
la cité de Magnus Naka firoga sont en
plus de facilité à switcher de l'un à
l'autre
que lui mais bon
c'est le jeu et sur ce 21h29 donc
du coup la surprise arrive parce que je
faisais gardé quand même pour la fin
j'ai la surprise
[Musique]
donc
un petit point direct
italienne nouvelle italienne chez
l'interview
l'interview de Fabi il a dit
effectivement elle était très surpris du
choix d'ouverture de
[Musique]
sirop parce que il a pas très bien
préparé visiblement il y a des coups qui
n'a pas compris donc il a confirmé qui
avait décidé à la place d'Oracle sinon
que de manière générale
les raisins est un joueur qui a des
hauts et des bas et là il a eu beaucoup
de bas dans cette partie même à la toute
fin et il a confirmé aussi que de
reprendre un chef dans ma fuite ça a pas
été vu par par Firo alors que nous on
l'a vu instantanément cette idée de ma
fuite donc et que voilà c'est à les
raisins est un joueur irrégulier qui est
capable de jouer brillamment et puis
tout d'un coup il a fait partie comme ça
sans donc voilà et sinon bah donc petite
un nouvel heureuse nouvelle pour les
fans de Fabi il a retrouvé sa deuxième
place pour que la forme mondiale donc
après une année très difficile l'année
passée là tout se passe bien et ça fait
plaisir voilà
ok bah très cool merci pour ce résumé
et donc
l'italienne a l'air de pas trop mal se
passer pour un bon Magnus
il va y avoir des échanges sur la
colonne ah le clouage est temporaire
parce que damocisse arrive sûrement
donc je vois très bien Magnus la perdre
en plus elle a pas de ça va
bon
c'est un coup c'est le couloir ce qu'il
a fait
tomber
impensable à Tours va se faire enfermer
la Tourette durablement pas de case en
fait pour l'instant on peut pas la voilà
elle est durablement en B5 c'est-à-dire
même si c'est un pion en B6
il a joué waouh alors
c'est 10 minutes pour les blancs contre
7 pour les Noirs mais en cas de nul et
ben c'est le noir qui gagne la partie
donc de 4 ans
il a raison
incroyable quoi et là tu vois il nous
refait un petit peu le remake de la
partie tout à l'heure on en parlait pas
blanc cas contre contre winter avec ce
full G3 qui qui qui est mauvais bon dans
la partie de Casablanca le Caval a été
changé il y a des plans qui sont doublés
c'est vraiment pire là c'est pas
vraiment la même mais
il y a un petit peu de ça quand même
de plus tout ce que tu veux mais en fait
en fait peut-être tourbé 5 et elles font
J3 il joue tellement pas que la
baignoire sont pas moins bien
d'accord
en B5 et la compréhension que du coup il
a prévu à l'avance magnifique
c'est pas un coup ça se regarde même pas
en fait ils ont vu plus loin
sur C6 on va manger et on va refaire la
même non
ça sent ouais il y a pas le choix
il veut ouvrir vraiment en plus là il y
a même des idées avec d'un premier six
des fois donc bon genre ca va les
prendre on peut prendre 5 ça a l'air
intéressant et le roi blanc il est il
est pas ouvert donc encore une fois il
aurait pu faire tourner 5 pour garder la
garder la tour
qui rentre dans la dans cette ligne et
c'est 5 va être joué tu es obligé de
faire
ça se joue avec la main comme on dit
parce qu'il veut garder le purin 5 ce
qui fait ça parce que le plus récent en
dehors le fou j'ai trois mais maintenant
moi il a un rôle quand même le fou il
bouge pas du coup j'ai trois il est
passé mal
non plus
[Musique]
il répond présent il doit absolument
l'emporter rappelons-le
leur dit que sévère avec les coups
quand tu peux le champion du monde
mais
tu as pas pu montrer avant donc l'idée
c'était de récupérer la tour à 6 par un
don d'intermédiaire et donc là il trouve
le sacrifice de dame magnifique
c'est vraiment une partie incroyable
en fait tu joues cavaler c'est 5 tu
joues aussi
à jouer le foin G3 on l'a critiqué toute
la partie mais regardez maintenant quel
rôle de penser qu'il tient
en fait chez les Blancs tu vois même pas
comment tu vas réussir à provoquer
mais avec les noirs on voit pas on voit
pas quoi opposer au simple plan de
pousser les pions d'ailleurs qui a
laissé 5 c'est pas du tout nécessaire
prends un coup de tour on peut jouer E5
cavaliers abscisse aussi etc
ça a l'air totalement gagnant la jauge
dit que c'est égal mais ça a l'air
totalement gagnant pour la blanc
[Musique]
idéalement on veut les bloquer avec le
roi donc croit aussi ça peut être un
coup
peut-être le plus économique dans cette
position ah oui oui c'est le problème
c'est que c'est un roi donc il peut
facilement se faire chasser mais si tu
le bloques avec la tour la dame façon tu
peux le faire à chasser et en plus ça
veut dire que tu utilises pas la tour ou
la dame en attaque donc tu as besoin
tant bien que mal de défendre
de les bloquer avec avec ce qui ce qui
vole moins cher en attaque donc le roi
idéalement un pion le meilleur pur passé
c'est celui qui n'est pas passé facile
bloqué par un pion
donc là ouais la jauge dit que c'est
égal mais ça a tellement l'air un joints
alors maintenant qu'on a joué F3
le plan tu auras vite tour à deux donne
du contrôle je mets juste est-ce qu'il y
a le temps ça se joue un petit si ça
tient ça tient temporaire
était magnifique tant que le pion est un
rêve de maintenant il y a du contre-jour
potentiel sur le rat blanc
franchement c'est chaotique ça a l'air
beaucoup plus facile à jouer pour les
blancs mais l'évaluation objective là on
voit on voit la barre ouais c'est plus
un quoi mais bon en plus ce qui est
marrant c'est que même matériellement tu
vois tu comptes les pièces tu vois
cavalier fou c'est 3 + 3,6 j'ai deux
pions plus 6 + 8 on est quasiment avec
le matériel en fait il y a ça en fait
que beaucoup de gens n'imaginent pas ils
comprennent pas parce que souvent ce
genre de sacrifice une de dames pour
plusieurs pièces pour plein de points tu
vois en tout cas j'ai quand même de moi
ouais mais tu as vu point tu vois donc
huit avec des pions 5 ça peut vite se
transformer en dame quand même donc
alors après ce qui sauve ce qui peut
sauver minus c'est que la nul lui fait
gagner cette armagny donc
si jamais il y a un père passe jamais il
y a quoi
en défense miraculeuse ça peut arriver
quand même
ça et le temps ouais mais alors le temps
il est mal au temps donc et puis c'est
que plus une seconde donc
c'est pas c'est pas un vrai
rajouter
de pervers quoi pour mettre plus une
seconde ouais bon c'est pour juste
passer
ça mais c'est vrai que tu peux te quand
même enfin tu tombes tout le temps en
fait tu vois
mais bon
tu fais gaffe tu tombes jamais une
seconde tu fais tomber les pièces bah tu
as pas le temps de ramasser donc a perdu
tu vois
il y a eu des 7 qui stabilise la tour
ici ça peut en plus j'ai trois deux à
cause de David dame il y a eu des cadres
enfin
après je suis pas obligé
pour cacher le roi un paquet
d'échecs
donc maintenant
[Musique]
ça c'est
bon
donc Laura Blokker on en parlait
et maintenant il a l'air d'être un bon
bloqueur quand même sur parce que le
cavalier n'a pas de cas évidente pour
faire un choc tant qu'il y avait le pur
en B4 il y avait la 4 c'est simple
a été mangé par Magnus
il y a plus et si on déloge pas le droit
on voit à quel point le pur le 5 gène
toutes les pièces blanches c'est
vraiment le jeu de blocage et la
limousovic quoi la tour E1 le fougère
par ce puret 5 il faut le bloquer
absolument
et donc un jour aussi
mais après ça a tellement compliqué
alors là il y a eu droit en fait mais
l'orchestre
de transmission voilà c'est bon
attention quel est le 4 à la logique une
prise je prends là j'ai plein de pièces
en fait donc c'est même pas si grave
matériellement je suis là j'ai deux
pièces et deux pions si je suis actif et
que je garde un peu passé etc je suis
encore vivant quoi après on est blanc en
partie aucun risque de perdre en tout
cas
il y a même des histoires où tu finis
avec une forteresse mais après on a
gagné c'est tellement quoi et le pioncer
il est assez anodin
ça reste ça reste très chaud
ça reste très chaud
donc il va devoir manger je pense parce
que c'est ce pion et le camiper
dangereux qu'il faut il faut aller le
manger
ils veulent manger est inquiète mais
il veut pas il veut pas t'inviter à sa
table tu vois
je mange
est-ce que c'est grave est-ce que c'est
grave
et si je donne mon cavale c'est grave
c'est nul
[Rires]
[Musique]
déjà la première chose
et sur C3
qui fait fourchette
[Musique]
c'est hyper intéressants sont finalement
échangés donc toujours le même rapport
matériel de cavalier foot de pions
contre la dame mais c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle que il y a de moins en
moins de pions sur l'échiquier et
surtout que le pire s'est disparu enfin
une bonne nouvelle
aux résultats je vais faire 100% et là
je suis pas loin d'être encore à 100%
[Musique]
nul guirina canule et là j'ai parlé
Google je suis pas loin de de la gagner
[Rires]
Magnus va tomber non mais c'est plus une
seconde
partie du match car ça n'est pas venu
en séance ça peut ça peut être chaud
ça peut être une bonne idée ou pas
deux secondes à la pendule pour Magnus
c'est plus une seconde parcours
[Musique]
mais c'est mort parce qu'en plus il a
joué il a joué cavalier 4 et finalement
il a la chance
était le meilleur coup l'ordinateur de
Mégane
malheureusement pour gagner ça va être
dur dame là F4 obligé qu'est-ce que ça
donne
sans fil ou pas
on a qu'une vie
en fait tu vois encore une fois
matériellement j'ai trois six
marrant cette position là
et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs la jauge elle a
été pendant un moment elle a été en
faveur de Google je passe t'as vu là il
y a quelques coups là mais bon ça allait
trop vite
je crois qu'il a fait tôt c'est 6 je
crois que la jauge elle a été en faveur
voilà ici là
[Musique]
et après ici pas évident
pas comprendre
et là il y a maintenant en fait
et ouais
c'est dur
donc un petit un petit rappel des
résultats tu as un joli classement ou
quoi nous proposer
oui alors je vais vous montrer je vais
vous montrer un petit peu le classement
actuel avec aussi les les résultats de
la journée en premier les résultats de
la journée hop ici vous avez donc gooche
qui vient de perdre l'Armageddon que
vous avez un point chacun parce que la
partie classique qu'ils ont fait nul
avec 4 personnes qui gagnent quand même
l'Armageddon donc un et demi pour
Carlson contre un on a ensuite un qui
perd l'Armageddon contre icarbonakamura
Ariana qui perd aussi l'Armageddon
contre so weisler
qui a fait un peu une non partie j'ai
l'impression Yoshua
un contre
jour là vraiment Fabi extraordinaire
dans ce tournoi il marche sur la
compétition crois avec toi en partie
classique une victoire en armée dedans
juste trop fort quoi et il repasse
numéro de mondial
blanche en Armageddon pour charia RAF
face à notre direback à boussatorov
pour le classement toute ma vie
vous avez toujours un carburant qui
creuse le car avec quatre points
d'avance sur
Ikaru Nakamura c'est c'est ouf 4 points
en fait en quatre parties c'est juste
c'est juste complètement ouf
aussi et c'est la 8e place actuelle de
Magnus Carson qui n'a pas gagné une
seule partie classique à la
effectivement trois fois les Noirs une
fois les blancs on pense à quatre
premières rondes mais mainus qui gagne
pas à domicile
c'est un rappelant qu'il a mis du temps
à gagner son premier dans watchesse
enfin il a pas gagné peut-être les cinq
premières éditions mais après là il
vient d'organiser quatre d'affilés ou un
truc comme ça c'est maintenant redevenu
son tournoi et là bah alors après
peut-être ça aussi qu'il l'a puni parce
que là ces derniers temps il a beaucoup
joué au poker il a fait des infidélités
au jeu d'échec et visiblement ça même
pour Magnus ça ne pardonne pas tu es
puni tout de suite par ca qui
refuse l'infidélité tout simplement donc
mon cher stuff c'était très plaisant le
commentaire avec toi cette quatrième
ronde on se revoit demain du coup bah je
crois hein faut demander au public
est-ce que le public est d'accord pour
qu'on se revoit demain à partir de 17h
donc je pense que oui on va pas faire le
vote sinon
c'est pour ça que bon on va pas aller
faire voter de toute façon demain on se
retrouve à partir de 7h et non pas on va
vite couper avant qu'il fasse le vote et
donc merci en tout cas d'avoir
accompagné aujourd'hui c'était hyper
cool
et merci à tous ceux qui m'ont suivi sur
YouTube sur sur twitch etc et je vous
dis à demain alors attends avant de
partir
je regardais un petit truc
j'aurais voulu faire un petit raid mais
malheureusement j'ai pas de Français qui
qui stream donc on va on va pas dread
aujourd'hui et oups voilà donc merci à
tous encore une fois
passez une excellente soirée et puis et
puis à demain Ciao